Musik
So, Test, Test, Test.
Es funzt. Oh, ich sehe gerade, die Lautstärke ist noch nicht richtig.
Ihr guckt, rechts ist mehr Lautstärke als links.
Das liegt daran, dass mein Audio Interface kaputt ist.
Und...
Also...
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie kacke es ist mittlerweile
In Windows
Die Settings zu finden
Für das Leveln
Von der Audio Balance
Ich hab Partner Jubiläum da
Guck mal an, das wusste ich gar nicht
Ihr wisst, steht das da irgendwo
Oder so, ich seh da nämlich nix
Steht da?
Okay, siehst du mal, so wusste ich nicht
Haha, excellent
So, guck mal
Pass mal auf
Ihr seht ja hier, die Audio Balance stimmt nicht ganz
Ne, also rechts ist mehr
Gebalanced als links
Das habe ich gestern eingestellt
Weil mein Audio Interface
Irgendwie ist da was kaputt
Und
Links ist ein bisschen mehr
als rechts vom Sound.
Das Audio Interface ist jetzt aber auch schon 12, 13 Jahre alt.
Vielleicht gibt es langsam den Geist,
auch weiß ich nicht.
So, und Sekunde.
Die Katz war gerade am Start.
Ja, Leute, ich finde das nice.
Ich sehe das bei mir gar nicht als Vorschau.
Witzig eigentlich.
Zumindest mein Audio Interface ist kaputt.
Das hat auf der linken Seite ein bisschen mehr Sound als auf der rechten Seite.
Vielleicht ist euch das auch schon aufgefallen, dass ich mich die letzten Streams gewundert habe,
ob mein Ohr irgendwie kaputt ist oder so.
Weil ich irgendwie links besser höre als rechts, aber das liegt gar nicht an meinem Ohr.
Das liegt am Audiointerface.
Das liegt auch nicht am Kopfhörer, weil es ist mit beiden Kopfhörern, die an unterschiedlichen Outputs angeschlossen sind.
Es ist das gleiche.
Wisst ihr, wie ich drauf gekommen bin, dass das nicht mein Ohr ist, sondern das Audio Interface?
Ich habe den Kopfhörer einfach links zu rechts aufgezogen.
Also ich habe den Kopfhörer normal aufgezogen und dann rumgedreht.
Und dann war es halt auf dem anderen Ohr zu laut, beziehungsweise zu leise.
Und dann bin ich drauf gekommen, okay, das muss ja eindeutig am Audio Interface liegen.
So, und jetzt passt mal auf.
Dann wollte ich unter Windows, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
und da wollte ich unter Windows
die Balance einstellen
vom Sound
dass halt der Sound ein bisschen mehr nach rechts
gebalanced wird, deswegen ist jetzt hier
auch die Sound Balance nicht ganz richtig
so
aber
wisst ihr auch
wie beschissen das mittlerweile zu finden ist
Chat, Chat mal ehrlich
wo würdet ihr suchen, wenn ihr
Wenn ihr links-rechts-Balance vom Sound einstellen wollt.
Wahrscheinlich hier, oder?
Hier würdet ihr auch gucken.
So, also hier geht schon mal nix.
So.
Dann hier vielleicht?
Ne.
Hier ist auch nix.
Volume-Mixer vielleicht?
Hm, ne.
Hier ist auch nix.
So, Rechtsklick.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Rechtsklick?
Sound-Settings vielleicht?
Ne.
Kann man auch nicht einschalten
Vielleicht hier beim Output
Ne, kann man auch nicht einstellen
So, passt mal auf
Ich zeige euch jetzt, wo das ist
Das ist so unglaublich dumm mittlerweile
Also früher
Bin ich mir relativ sicher
Hattest du im alten Mixer
Die Möglichkeit Left, Right zu machen
Also ihr wisst ja, als mir unten noch ein Mixer
Ausfahren konnte
So, guckt mal, wo das jetzt ist
Du musst
Ins Control Panel
Was sonst?
Dann musst du unter Hardware und Sounds
Sounds
das Audio
Output auswählen.
Levels
Balance
Was ein Trash, oder?
Wer zum Teufel
soll denn das finden?
So.
Und jetzt habt ihr auch wieder den Sound
auf beiden Seiten gleich.
Oder auch nicht.
Aber das liegt jetzt an der Musik und nicht am Sound.
Es ist halt richtig beknackt, oder?
Was das verstellt hat, dass der Sound bei euch jetzt links und rechts aus dem Kopfhörer gleich stark rauskommt.
Vorher war es so, dass der Sound quasi mehr links als rechts...
Ne, mehr rechts als links.
Apropos, hast du das mitbekommen, Microsoft LG-Monitoren...
Zum Teil habe ich das mitbekommen.
Ich habe da nur ganz kurz was drüber gelesen.
Also es muss ja wohl so gewesen sein, dass Microsoft über das Windows Update...
Warum es überhaupt unbalanced ist, weil mein Audio Interface irgendwelche Probleme hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht, was das hat.
Es liegt aber auch eindeutig am Audio Interface, weil ich habe den Kopfhörer linksrum und rechtsrum aufgezogen und es ist dann halt immer auf dem anderen Ohr zu laut.
Und es ist mit beiden Kopfhörern an beiden Outputs.
Also das muss irgendwas vom Audio Interface sein, dass das Probleme macht.
Also keine Ahnung, was das genau für Probleme hat.
Ja, weil mein Sound hier und so, das ist ja alles Mikrofon Sound, ist alles okay.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, also ich habe das am Rande so ein bisschen mitgekriegt.
Und zwar habe ich auf Reddit gelesen, dass über einen Windows-Update, also Alfred, du kannst das ja genauer erklären, ich habe das wie gesagt nur so ganz kurz 20 Sekunden oder so gelesen, also Microsoft muss wohl, wenn man einen LG-Monitor hat, über einen Windows-Update irgendwelche komische Treiber-Software verteilen, die dann zum Aufruf von McAfee Antivirus aufruft oder sowas.
Habe ich das richtig gelesen auf Reddit?
Wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Ich habe das irgendwie 20 Sekunden oder so beim drüber scrollen gelesen.
Ist das so?
LG Monitor Microsoft.
News.
Ah ja, doch hier, guck mal da.
Da ist es doch.
Hier.
Es ist halt für den Arsch, ne?
Es ist halt einfach für den Arsch, so unter Windows.
LG Monitor App Installer.
Der automatisch über Windows Update drauf landet.
Ja, die haben halt nicht richtig nachgeguckt, was sie da automatisch verteilen.
Wie sieht die Werbung aus?
Weiß ich nicht, sieht man das hier vielleicht?
Okay, das ist irgendein KI-Bild oder so wahrscheinlich.
Tja, weiß ich nicht, ob man da...
Vielleicht müssen wir auf Reddit gucken.
Windows Update silently installs LG Plotware.
Ach hier, guck, so sieht die Werbung anscheinend aus.
LG Monitor App Installer.
Stay safer.
Geil.
Mit dieser dummen Scareware-Werbung.
Das will man natürlich haben.
tolle werbung ganz toll das application was installt bei der windows-store
silent die windows update
jetzt kriegst du schon irgendeinen scam scheiß weil monitor angeschlossen hast
gut aber das sind so sachen muss ehrlich sagen das kann ja schon passieren
Microsoft wird wahrscheinlich nicht jedes Update, was sie vom Hersteller zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen für Windows Update, also jedes 3-Bar-Update exzessiv testen nochmal.
Die gehen einfach davon aus, wenn das über offizielle Quellen von LG bei denen ankommt, dann wird das schon für LG-Hardware okay sein.
Die eigentlichen Ficker sind ja hier eigentlich die LG-Leute, dass sie so eine komische App haben, die dumme Werbung raushaut.
Das Ding ist halt, wisst ihr, das erste, was ich gedacht hätte, wenn ich so ein Pop-Up bekomme, das erste, was ich gedacht hätte, ist, oh shit, ich hab mir irgendein Virus eingefangen.
So, wisst ihr, es kommt ja öfter, es gibt ja so Malware, die so tut, als hat sie 30 Viren gefunden und verkauft euch jetzt gleich quasi den Antivirus dazu.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass es irgendein Scam ist.
Wenn ich da jetzt auf GoToMcAfee drücke,
komme ich bei irgendeinem China-Chinesen-Ding raus, Installer,
was gar nicht McAfee ist, aber anscheinend ist es wirklich eine offizielle Werbung.
Also, irgendeine Werbung, die die halt da eingebaut haben.
Aber da musst du dich schon mal erinnern.
Die eigentlichen Deppen sind halt LG.
LG.
Microsoft hätte es besser
testen können, beziehungsweise
besser nochmal kontrollieren können.
Ja, das hätten die schon machen können.
Aber eigentlich sind die Deppen hier LG.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Also hier richtig für den Arsch.
Ist ihr was ich witzig finde?
Wie korrekt eigentlich die Werbung ist.
McAfee Scam Risk.
Ja, dein Risk gescamt zu werden,
steigt entschieden an.
Zum Beispiel, dass du hast,
Aber die meinen, es ist ja umgedreht.
Die meinen, dass du ohne krasses Scam-Risk hast.
Unter Linux wäre das nicht passiert.
Das ist richtig.
Suchen wir mal, ob es da was Neues gibt.
Außer, dass alle drüber berichten.
Hat sich LG irgendwie schon mal auf X oder so geäußert?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was mich jetzt... Warte mal.
Wisst ihr, was mich auch interessiert?
Taugt der denn überhaupt...
Okay, das ist egal.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, taugt der dem Monitor überhaupt was?
Aber das ist...
Ist ja anscheinend egal, welcher LG-Monitor.
Hauptsache LG.
Ist halt so dumm.
Ah.
Ja, witzig, dass ihr das alles seht.
Ich sehe das bei mir selbst gar nicht angezeigt.
Was? Da wird überhaupt nichts passieren.
Das ist Microsoft scheißegal, das ist LG scheißegal.
Das Einzige, was LG interessiert, ist vielleicht die negative Presse jetzt mal kurzfristig.
Aber passieren wird da nichts.
Nö, nö, nö, du kannst mir das nicht vorstellen.
Microsoft ist ja selbst da kein Deut besser.
Mit Features in Anführungszeichen, die keiner haben will.
So Leute, ich mach mal kurz hier den Mini-PC an.
Ja, Normal Mode.
Desk Flow muss gestartet werden.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Oh, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz...
Ich sehe gerade, ich habe ja immer noch Ukraine-Wärmung drin.
Das wollte ich das letzte Mal mal.
Nightbot?
Warte mal, ich werde das gerade mal...
Ah, fuck, ich kann mich nicht einloggen.
No, shit.
Okay.
Commands.
Sekunde.
Wo ist es denn?
Timers.
Ukraine Seagate.
Okay, zack.
Ist ausgeschaltet.
So, achso, ich muss hier mal Passwort eingeben.
Zack.
Musik ist ein bisschen laut, hä?
Waren wir hier auf 70%?
Das ist ein bisschen leise.
Ah ne, die Musik ist gerade vorbei.
Eins lauter können wir nochmal.
Ja, exzellent.
Das Banner ist auch noch da.
Oh.
Ne, das Banner ist nicht mehr da.
Achso, du meinst auf dem Channel.
Ähm, du hast recht.
Moment, äh, wie?
Dann muss ich nachher gucken.
Was ist das für eine Frage, Alter?
WTF? Was ist das für eine Frage?
Als würde ich jetzt sagen,
ja, so schlimm finde ich das gar nicht.
Oder wie?
Natürlich finde ich das schlecht
Ach die Geschichte meins
Ja
Wisst ihr was
Jetzt Kek-Alu-Time.
Kek-Alu-Time.
Richtig, richtig Hardcore-Kek-Alu-Time.
Es gab ja in letzter Zeit sehr viele unbeliebte Entscheidungen, die getroffen wurden.
Sowohl in Deutschland als auch auf EU-Ebene.
Und da steht ja noch deutlich mehr an.
Ich hab irgendwie den Eindruck, dass diese ganze Jens Spahn Geschichte irgendwie vorgeschoben ist
Dass sich alle da drauf stürzen und sich nichts anderes mehr angucken
Wie gesagt, Hardcore Cake Alu Time
Das ist
Das ist natürlich auch
Das ist natürlich auch eine Domain, Alter
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
Updates machen und dann
Rebooten
Oh, Jetbrains.
Updates.
Oh, krass.
Irgendwas im Auge.
Was ist das für eine hässliche Seite hier?
Wo bin ich denn hier gelandet?
Alter, was ist das?
Das ist ja die hässlichste Seite, die ich je gesehen habe, ey.
Ah, die Realtek-Seite.
Ja gut, die sieht hässlich aus.
Das ist nichts Neues.
Aber das sieht schon hässlich aus, die Seite, oder?
Multi-Million-Dollar-Company.
Da ist natürlich klar, dass man so eine hässliche Abwachsseite braucht.
So, was machen die Updates?
Wurde Kernel geupdatet? Ich habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt.
Linux? Nee, oder? Dann werden wir gleich sehen.
Die machen auch Netzwerkkarten.
Die machen Soundchips, die machen Netzwerkkarten, die machen glaube ich noch ein bisschen mehr Zeug, Realtek.
Aber zumindest haben sie eine sehr hässliche Webseite.
Witzigerweise sieht die Webseite seit 15 Jahren oder so gleich aus.
Ich will noch kurz was trinken.
Die Seite für die Treiber ist so schlecht.
Ja, ich meine, guckt euch das an, Alter.
Vor allem das hier unten.
Das sieht halt so schlecht aus.
Warum braucht das jetzt eigentlich so lange?
Ah, DaVinci Resolve wird runtergeladen.
DaVinci Resolve ist halt
super Pipo-Fett-Software.
Guck mal.
Das sind halt ein paar Gigabyte.
Ich könnte das übrigens wieder aninstallen.
Ich benutze das da eh nicht drauf.
Wahrscheinlich wäre das taktisch deutlich geschickter.
Was ist das hier schon wieder für ein Paket?
Python Types, Python Date Utils.
Aha.
Sieht aus wie ein Bug von der Seite.
Es könnte übrigens auch, fällt mir gerade auf, am Dark Reader liegen.
Naja.
Leute.
So viel besser sieht die Seite auch ohne Dark Reader nicht aus, oder?
Es sieht nicht ganz so kacke aus.
Okay.
Aber es sieht trotzdem kacke aus.
Ups.
Ja, schöne Webseite ist was anderes.
Auf Mini-PC mach hin.
Wie viel CPU auslassen?
Oh, Alter.
Der hat mal Hardcore-CPU-Auslastung gerade durch Updates.
Guckt euch das mal an.
16 Kerne, alle mehr oder weniger ausgelastet.
Okay, 16 stimmt nicht.
Das ist ja nur Fake.
Das sind 8 Kerne mit Hyperthreading 16.
Überlegt euch mal, wie lange das jetzt unter Red Hat gedauert hätte.
Unter einem älteren Red Hat.
Red Hat hat auch deutlich zugelegt, was die Geschwindigkeit angeht von Yam.
Eigentlich ist es DNF.
Chat, Chat, mal Frage an alle
Redhead-User, die es vielleicht
halt auch auf der Arbeit benutzen müssen
Benutzt ihr DNF oder
immer noch YAM?
Ich benutze immer noch YAM. Letztendlich ist YAM ja glaube ich
mittlerweile sogar DNF
im Kompatibilitätsmodus oder sowas
Aber ich benutze kein DNF
Ich mache alles mit YAM
Ich habe mir das einmal gemerkt, dass YAM der Package-Manager
ist unter Redhead
und das werde ich jetzt für immer verwenden
Ich glaube, es gab kein
Kernel-Update, ne?
Doch.
Doch, es gab Kernel-Update.
Ja, Kernel-Update heißt,
wir müssen eigentlich rebooten.
Wir können es uns aber auch schenken, weil letztendlich
Firefox geht ja auch weiter.
Und das hier mal weg.
Gucken wir mal, ob JetBrains geupdatet hat.
Jawoll.
Excellent, excellent.
So, gut.
Ansonsten, Chat, was gab es in die Woche sonst noch Spannendes?
Ich muss mal gucken.
Ich habe mir ja vorgenommen,
also ich scrolle ja immer
auf der Fahrt nach Frankfurt auf Reddit.
Ich scrolle auf der Rückfahrt auf Reddit
Manchmal, wenn ich nichts zu tun habe
Mich mal kurz ein bisschen im Kopf ablenken muss
Scrolle ich Reddit
Und ich habe mir jetzt eigentlich vorgenommen
Ich favorite mir
Reddit Posts
Wo ich denke, dass das Thema interessant ist
Mal gucken, was ich mir diese Woche gefavoritet habe
So wie ich
Gibt es das gar nicht mehr?
Ah hier, saved, genau
Okay
Die Sachen, die ich mir gesaved hab
Sind komplett unsinnig für den Stream
Katzenpost 1
Katzenpost 2
Katzenpost 3
Katzenpost 4
Okay, nee, das bringt nix
Du bist IT-Hausmeister
Was macht man denn als IT-Hausmeister?
Ist das sowas wie Turnschuh-Admin?
Moin, Mr. Radish.
Ach, du hast die Physie-Ausbildung bestanden?
GZ, GG, ITS.
Und wie schwer war die mündliche Prüfung?
Haben sie dich irgendwas Nerviges gefragt in der mündlichen Prüfung?
so sie modellschichten oder irgendwie sowas
der ausschuss war anstrengender ich glaube das ist für die meisten mal ein bisschen stressig
wie gesagt ich hab's schon oft erzählen ich hatte mega glück mit dem ausschuss die haben
mich nichts gefragt die haben einfach nur gefragt und hat funktioniert ich habe gesagt ja und dann
war das Fachgespräch zu Ende.
Aber, wie gesagt, da steckt ja noch
ein bisschen mehr dahinter. Ich habe euch die Story
mit meiner Abschlussarbeit, die sie
irgendwie verloren haben, habe ich euch ja schon öfters
erzählt. Da habe ich sogar ein eigenes Video
zugemacht.
Aber ich hier,
wen die ganze Story interessiert von meiner
Abschlussarbeit hier,
könnt ihr euch
das Video angucken.
Auf YouTube.
Es hat mittlerweile 104.000 Aufrufe.
Pog.
Was ist die sichere Variante von HTTP?
Die Frage könnte man natürlich auch
super deep
angehen. Aber wahrscheinlich
wollen die einfach nur HTTPS hören.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Über mir haben die schon drinnen gehockt.
Oh, die wollten es aber wissen hier
Und Portnummern wollten sie wissen
Achso, Leute, ich habe übrigens
Rufbereitschaft, es kann sein, dass ich angerufen werde
Während ich stream so
Da muss ich ausmachen und irgendwas fixen
Falls was kaputt ist
Aber ich glaube nicht
Ich glaube nicht, dass die anrufen
Ich habe das glaube ich gestern noch gelesen
Per Mail, dass sie eigentlich fertig sind
Die haben Wartungsarbeiten gemacht
Haben Wartungsarbeiten
Eingeplant
Für gestern und heute
Ich glaube gestern Abend
Haben die noch eine Mail geschickt, wo drin steht, dass sie fertig sind
Was nicht zwangsläufig heißt, dass sie fertig sind
Also falls die da irgendwas gewartet haben
Und heute geht es kaputt
Aber die Chancen
Ich sag mal, die Chancen sind nicht so groß
Dass die mich jetzt anrufen
Einfach im Stream fixen
Ey, wisst ihr wie
Ups, wisst ihr wie gern ich das machen würde
Aber es geht nicht
Ich würde das
Mega gerne machen
Einfach mal so wirklich realistisches
Äh
Wie heißen diese Videos
Ähm
A day in the life
Of a
Was auch immer
Server Admin of a Software Engineer und sowas
Das würde ich so gerne machen
realistisches, ein realistisches
Tag,
ja, ich würde einfach
8 Stunden streamen, das darf ich aber natürlich nicht.
Darf ich nicht.
Erstens,
leake ich mich da selbst,
wo ich arbeite, wie ich heiße
und was sonst noch alles, genau, ja.
Und,
es ist natürlich auch so,
da sieht man sicherlich die
ein oder anderen Sachen, die
eigentlich nicht
unbedingt jetzt öffentlich gezeigt
werden sollen. Ja.
Zweifelsfall zeige ich noch irgendwelche Passwörter an oder so.
Nee, nee. Also, wie gesagt, das würde
ich mega gerne machen, aber es geht nicht.
Yes, der Graupfell ist dead.
Könntest dich filmen, wie du Tasten tippst. Ja, geil.
Ja, guck mal, Leute.
Das ist der Stack-Overflow-Traffic.
Seit KI.
Hier war Corona.
Da haben die Leute daheim gesessen und programmieren gelernt.
Und hier ging das...
Und hier so ging das ja dann...
Naja, ne.
Sagen wir mal, hier so, hä?
Hier so ging das dann mit KI los.
Und dann...
Ich muss aber auch dazu sagen, also mittlerweile ist es bei mir auch so, ich gucke mehr in die KI rein, als dass ich google und stack overflow.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht. Googeln ist glaube ich immer noch, ne das stimmt nicht.
Googeln ist immer noch meine Default-Sache, weil es einfach noch ein bisschen schneller geht, als eine Frage in die KI eintippen.
Aber ansonsten
Für alles was wirklich
Ein bisschen komplexer ist
Als so ganz simple Sachen
Da frage ich mittlerweile auch lieber KI
Wir haben jetzt auf der Arbeit übrigens ein Update bekommen
Was unsere interne KI Geschichte angeht
Also es ist ja so
Die wollen ja nicht
Dass unsere internen Daten verwendet werden
um irgendwelche Models zu trainieren
und wo du nicht genau weißt, wo die hinkommen.
Deswegen haben wir ja so einen eigenen
Chat-GPT-Fork von Microsoft gekauft.
Der wird auch mit unseren internen Wikis
und was auch immer nicht,
da wir da noch haben, gefüttert.
Und mittlerweile,
vor zwei Wochen oder so,
gab es da ein Model-Update
und das ist echt ganz gut brauchbar.
Wir haben da jetzt Opus 4.8,
Gemini 3.
Punkt. Was ist das?
3.1 oder 3.5?
Ein neues GPT?
Das ist mittlerweile echt ganz gut brauchbar.
Davor war es halt komplett useless, weil
wir Models hatten, die ein Jahr alt waren.
Und ihr wisst, wie schnell da die
Entwicklung geht.
Also ein Jahr altes Model verwendet keiner mehr.
Wo wird der gehostet?
Ich glaube in Azure.
Das ist irgendein Service, den Microsoft anbietet.
Da kannst du deine KI quasi bei Microsoft hosten und die garantieren dir dann auch, dass das irgendwie in Europa bleibt oder sogar in Deutschland bleibt oder keine Ahnung.
Ob das natürlich dann wirklich so ist, das kann dir keiner sagen, weil du kannst ja nicht nachgucken im Hintergrund, was Microsoft da macht.
Ich habe doch vor einer Woche erzählt, dass ich eine Mr. Robot Präsentation
in der Schule vorbereitet habe. Ich habe sie gehalten.
Ging zwei Stunden. Ach ja, nice.
Aber da hast du ein bisschen länger gebraucht
als ursprünglich geplant.
Excellent, excellent.
Ja, ne?
Präsentieren, presentaten
macht Spaß, wenn es ein Thema
ist, was einen interessiert.
Und wenn man Ahnung von dem Thema hat und man merkt, dass die Leute irgendwie das auch so ein bisschen aufsaugen, ja, dann macht das Spaß.
Ich presentate mittlerweile auch gern.
Wo ist das der Vorteil, wenn es nicht bei euch gehostet wird?
Ja gut, dass Microsoft einem zusichert, dass die Daten in Europa oder in Deutschland bleiben.
Und keine internen Daten irgendwo hinabfließen.
Das ist der Vorteil.
Ob die das wirklich machen, können wir natürlich nicht wissen.
IQ Boost, Dankeschön.
POG, Massive Subscription.
Dazu kann man nur sagen...
Oh, die Musik.
Moment, ich habe hier Mist eingestellt.
Oh, jetzt passt es.
Ich habe zu leise eingestellt.
Letztendlich sind alle Verträge, wo es darum geht,
dass die dir irgendwas garantieren, wo du nicht selbst überprüfen kannst,
was du bei den meisten nicht kannst, die sind alle Trust Me Pro.
Hat aber den Vorteil, so im Business Enterprise Umfeld,
dass du halt sagen kannst, du hast dich drum gekümmert.
Das ist wichtig.
Da geht es einfach nur um rechtliche Sicherheit, würde ich mal behaupten.
Sind hier Leute die ursprünglichen
Switches einer...
Was? Was ist das denn?
Ich kann doch nicht...
Ist das eine Tastatur?
Nee.
Okay, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll, aber...
Vielleicht sind ja hier Leute, die das können.
Ja, das ist im Business Enterprise Umfeld oftmals so
Hauptsache es ist auf dem Papier so
Ob es wirklich dann so ist, juckt keinen
So, Updates haben wir gemacht
Dann gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub so trendet
Wie sieht es eigentlich aus?
zu deiner Mr. Robot Präsentation
gab es da jetzt wenigstens auch eine gute Note
für?
Also hast du denn jetzt wenigstens auch was davon gehabt?
Dass du die gemacht hast?
Tastatur, kannst ja mal googeln
Chinesis Advantage 2
kann man danach googeln, wer weiß
was dann passiert
Ach, so ein Ding ist das
Ich weiß ja nicht
Das ist ja abgedreht
Ich habe auf YouTube schon öfters mal jemand gesehen
Moment, Moment
Auf YouTube gucke ich manchmal
Irgendeinen Channel
Der heißt irgendwas mit
devops toolbox oder so der da der da genau genau genau der hat es gucken wir uns jetzt
nicht an ich will euch bloß welche der hat so eine ganz abgedreht guckt euch das an mit
Was ist das für eine Tastatur, Alter?
Könntet ihr so arbeiten?
Das sieht auch übelst krass aus, wenn der tippt.
Man sieht es jetzt nicht richtig, wie er tippt.
Aber das hier, guckt mal.
da fuck
sieht bequem aus keine ahnung ob das wirklich so bequem ist dass das also ich
ich würde ich würde es nicht benutzen aus zwei gründen
die haupt der hauptsächliche kund ist weil es wahrscheinlich richtig lange
dauert bis du dich daran gewöhnt hast ja ich öfters auch noch meine maus
verwende gerade für webbrowser unsere browser geht am besten noch mit maus
und mein hauptsächlicher
Grund, das was ja auch der hauptsächliche
Grund ist, warum ich viele anderen
weiterentwickelte Tools
nicht verwende, so nach dem Motto
warum verwende
ich kein Rust Rewrite
von LS und sowas, ja
weil ich dann auf Server nicht mehr genau
weiß, wie das ursprüngliche LS funktioniert
wenn ich mich an zusätzliche Parameter
gewöhne und so ist es bei der Tastatur
auch, dann sitzt du mal vor einer normalen
Tastatur und
die kommen so vor, als sitzen sie
erst mal im Leben vor einer normalen Tastatur.
Genau.
Das ist so mein Problem.
Ich finde das geil, dass ihr das
alle mit dem Partnerjubiläum seht. Bei mir wird das
überhaupt nicht angezeigt.
Ja, aber das ist abgedreht, die Tastatur.
Und ein bisschen daran erinnert mich das
hier halt auch.
Wie schnell kann er tippen? Schnell.
Nein, ich bin kein Primogen-Enjoyer.
Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Ich habe ganz wenig Videos von ihm geguckt.
Aber das ist mir zu anstrengend.
Ich kann mir das nicht angucken.
Ich muss für meine Masterarbeit
einen digitalen Anhang machen.
Wo kann ich das hochladen und bereitstellen?
Ja, da kriegst du doch bestimmt
von deiner Uni.
Oder von der Schule, wo du halt hingehst.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt eine Plattform, wo du das hochladen kannst, oder?
Also bei der IHK, weiß ich, ist es immer so, die haben eine Plattform, da musst du draufgehen und musst deine Sachen hochladen.
Ich habe auf die Präsi dreimal eine 1 bekommen.
Dreimal eine 1.
Excellent.
Ja, würde ich auch machen.
Würde ich auch machen.
Weil wir können hier viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Nicht, dass du es am Ende irgendwo hochlädst
und die sagen, Sachen darauf akzeptieren wir nicht,
weil man es nachträglich noch editieren kann
oder irgendwas in der Richtung, ja.
Also da würde ich schon mal
auf Nummer sicher gehen.
Safari-Emulator-Sandbox.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Kenne nicht.
Was trinken, ey?
Ja, Chat, ich weiß nicht genau.
Habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Silicon Valley.
Aber vielleicht sollte ich das
mal zum Upliken ein bisschen gucken.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, wie lange ich am Start bin heute.
Mir geht es die letzten Tage eigentlich nicht so dolle.
Mal schauen.
Einfach USB-Stick.
Ja, wie gesagt, also ich glaube, am besten bist du echt, wenn du den Betreuer fragst.
So, dann schauen wir mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Nein, das wollen wir nicht.
GitHub Trends.
Moin.
Du bist im Fahrrad-Cry.
Ich habe mein Fahrrad immer noch nicht repariert.
MonkaW.
Moin.
Schön, dass du wieder mal am Start bist.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ich habe mein Fahrrad immer noch nicht repariert.
Dafür habe ich mir Inlineskates gekauft.
wieder. Ich hatte da so Bock drauf.
Ich bin früher viel gefahren. Das ist ja überhaupt
nicht mehr angesagt. Kein Mensch fährt
heute mehr Inlineskates.
Aber ich bin früher viel gefahren. Ich habe mir jetzt wieder
welche gekauft. Also ich habe erstmal meine
alten angezogen wieder.
Was ist am Rad kaputt?
Ich hoffe nur das Schaltauge verbogen.
Äh, Skateboard ist
nicht meins. Also
ich habe erstmal meine alten Inlineskates
angezogen und ich habe festgestellt,
Alter, mir tut der Fuß
da drin weh.
Und ich
bin viel zu wackelig
geworden mittlerweile. Also ich hatte
früher, die sind 15 Jahre alt, ja.
Früher bin ich diese
Dinger hier gefahren.
Die Dinger.
Diese Teile.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Die bin ich früher gefahren.
Das sind advanced Skates schon gewesen.
Also quasi welche, die auch schon ein bisschen weicher waren und nicht so hoch und so.
Also da hattest du recht viel Freiheit.
Früher konnte ich damit ganz gut fahren.
Jetzt, ich bin so oft umgeknickt und so, hab mega verschissen, ja.
Also das sind meine alten.
Aber ich bin mit denen so 40 Minuten gefahren und hab mir gedacht, ey, weißt du was?
eigentlich hast du da schon richtig
Bock drauf.
Und jetzt habe ich mir ein bisschen
einsteigerfreundlichere gekauft.
Jetzt habe ich mir hier
so welche gekauft.
Endlich mal welche.
Ich bin froh, dass die das auch haben.
Und zwar
Guck mal, die haben sich das abgeguckt von Schuhen fürs Fahrrad.
Die haben jetzt auch so einen Bohrverschluss vorne.
Seht ihr das da oben in der Mitte?
Dieses Ding zum Drehen?
Das gibt es bei Fahrradschuhen schon eine ganze Weile.
Du hast da keinen Klettverschluss mehr oder sowas.
Sondern du drehst das einfach.
Und wenn du es drehst...
Ich würde ja gerne das Bild groß machen, das darf man nicht.
Ihr seht ja diese Schnüre, die da dran gehen, diese Metallschnüre.
So, und wenn du das drehst, dann wickelst du quasi die Schnüre auf und es wird enger.
Das ist super easy, quasi da reinzukommen dann.
Also du drückst da drauf auf den Knopf, dann geht das auf, gehst rein, drehst das zu.
Das ist quasi wie ein Schuhn fürs Fahrrad, dieser Bohrverschluss.
Das ist eigentlich mega nice, ja.
Und ansonsten hat das halt viel mehr Support als die alten, die ich hatte.
Und was auch richtig cool aussieht ist, die haben so eine einseitige Montage.
Guck mal, du kannst dir die Rollen angucken.
Normalerweise hast du ja hier beidseitig diesen Dings zum Halten von den Rollen.
Eigentlich ganz cool, ja.
Naja.
Aber mega Bock gemacht.
Gleich Stunde 15 eingefahren die Dinger.
Hat richtig Spaß gemacht.
Es ist halt überhaupt nicht mehr im Trend, ne.
Du wirst schon schepp angeguckt, wenn du da am Main langfährst.
So nach dem Motto, oh, was ist denn das? Ist der vor 15 Jahren stehen geblieben oder so?
Aber, wenig juckt's.
Mit Inlinern konnte ich nie bremsen.
Ich bremse nicht mit der Bremse, ich bremse seit jeher schon quasi mit den Rollen.
Mit den Rollen.
Also du nimmst einfach den rechten Fuß.
Drehst den so zur Seite.
Und ziehst halt die Rollen über den Boden.
Das Problem ist halt, dass die Rollen dadurch abgenutzt werden schneller.
Ich hatte mein Outfit an, was ich sonst auch zum Joggen immer anziehe.
Natürlich bei der ersten Ausfahrt, bei beiden Inlineskater, ich bin seit 15 Jahren oder so nicht mehr gefahren.
Bei der ersten Ausfahrt natürlich kein Helm, keine Schoner angehabt.
Und auch nicht aufs Maul gefallen.
YOLO.
Ey, hallo, ich bin mittlerweile recht sportlich, ja.
Leider ist mein Fahrrad kaputt.
Ich muss da irgendwie mal gucken, dass ich das endlich auf die Reihe kriege.
Laut meiner Garmin-Uhr, Leute,
habe ich mittlerweile wieder einen VO2 Max von 46.
Und das ist angeblich in Top 25% für mein Alter und Gender.
Merkwürdig, dass Garmin noch keinen Shitstorm gekriegt hat, weil die in ihrem Report schreiben Alter und Gender.
Also das ist wohl ganz okay.
Ob es wirklich stimmt, was Garmin da errechnet, keine Ahnung.
Aber als ich mir die Garmin Uhr damals gekauft habe, beziehungsweise die erste Garmin Uhr
Als ich mir die damals gekauft habe, da hatte ich glaube ich einen VO2 Max von 34 oder so
Wirst du immer noch angelächelt? Ab und zu, ja
Also man merkt schon, dass das deutlich besser ankommt mit 25 Kilo weniger und insgesamt deutlich fitter
Was das heißt
Was ist V und 2 Max
Das ist
Ich kann es euch wissenschaftlich
Nicht exakt erklären
Aber ich kann euch so ungefähr erklären was es bedeutet
Und zwar ist das
Was du quasi
Ich glaube in der Minute
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Wie viel Sauerstoff du quasi
In Leistungsoutput umsetzen kannst
Das ist quasi
Die Metrik für Fitness
Schlechthin
Also wie viel, weil das letztendlich alles beinhaltet
Also wie viel Sauerstoff du aufnehmen kannst
Wie gut du das verarbeiten kannst
Wie gut dein Herz-Kreislauf-System ist
Wie gut deine Muskeln sind und so
Genau, genau
VO2max, maximales Sauerstoffaufnahmen
Das maximale Volumen an Sauerstoff
dass ihr Körper während intensiver Belastung pro Minute und Kilogramm Körpergewicht aufnehmen und verwerten kann.
Also quasi das, was du in Sauerstoff in Leistung outputten kannst.
Das ist wohl die Metrik für Fitness schlechthin.
Das Einzige, was es sonst noch gibt, ist, im Radsportbereich ist Watt pro Kilogramm auch noch sehr beliebt.
Aber du siehst, das Gute an diesen Metriken ist, dass das immer das Körpergewicht quasi mit einbezieht.
Weil es ist beim Fahrradfahren ja auch so, dass, also oftmal so, stellt euch mal vor, jemand der richtig krass muskulös gebaut ist, ja, und auch dementsprechend was wiegt, auf ebener Strecke tritt er wahrscheinlich maximal mehr Watt als jemand, der deutlich leichter ist.
Aber wenn man das dann auf Watt pro Kilogramm umrechnet, ist das im Fahrradbereich, passt sich das an?
Und die sind eh komplett krank.
Wenn man sich anguckt, was sie teilweise für Werte bei der Tour de France oder bei anderen Rennen treten, das ist komplett nicht normal.
Die sind da teilweise bei an die 7 Watt pro Kilogramm Körpergewicht.
Für, keine Ahnung, 30 Minuten oder so.
Das ist total gestört.
Also ich bin froh.
Ich bin froh, wenn ich auf meinem Indoor-Trainer für 45 Minuten 2,2 Watt pro Kilogramm Körpergewicht mittlerweile treten kann.
Ich war schon mal ein bisschen besser.
Da bin ich froh, wenn ich das auf die Reihe kriege mittlerweile.
Das ist halt komplett gestört.
und als ich
nur mal so zum Vergleich
als ich mit den Inline Skates gefahren bin
ich bin ziemlich genau 20 Kilometer
gefahren, so 21, 22, 23
irgendwie so in dem Dreh, Kilometer
und ich hab
das aufgezeichnet
und ich hatte, leider hatte ich noch
Running noch drin stehen
der hat gesagt
ich bin
diese 20 Kilometer im Durchschnitt
mit einem 3,15er Pace gefahren.
Also 3 Minuten 15 pro Kilometer.
Und jetzt ist halt das krasse, ich bin das mit Inlineskates gefahren
und das kam mir schon relativ schnell vor.
Zwischendurch, ja.
Und ihr müsst euch vorstellen,
der Weltrekord im Marathon,
der rennt schneller
über 40 Kilometer,
als ich im Durchschnitt den Kilometer
mit den Inlineskates gefahren bin.
Ich glaube,
der Marathon-Weltrekord hat einen Pace
von
von 2,55
oder irgendwie sowas.
Also die rennen
irgendwie 21 kmh
oder sowas in dem Dreh.
So Pi mal Daumen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ja, irgendwie 21 kmh
rennen die für
zwei Stunden über 40 Kilometer.
Oder über 42,
41, irgendjemandes Kilometer.
Das ist so krass, die Leute. Das kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie heftig das ist.
Also wenn ich, wenn ich,
wenn ich entspannte, entspannte Runde
renne, ja, entspannte Runde,
aktuell,
aktuell ist entspannte Runde
bei mir 6,40er Pace.
Aber das ist wirklich entspannt, ja.
Das kriege ich von meiner Uhr auch immer angezeigt,
als,
Base, Auslagen, Dauer, Trainingspace.
Ja, 6,40.
Ich kann auch 5,20 rennen,
dann ist es schon wirklich anstrengend.
Da packe ich
5 Kilometer gerade mal
mit Ach und Krach, ja.
Aber wenn ich schneller renne als
5,20, manchmal muss ich auch so
eine halbe Minute, schlägt dann meine
Uhr vor, so eine halbe Minute muss ich 4,30
rennen oder sowas. Das kann ich höchstens
1 Kilometer oder 2 maximal,
dann bin ich am Arsch. Also,
Also die längeren Runden, die renne ich so mit 6,30 bis 6,40.
Und da muss ich mal vorstellen, die rennen mehr als doppelt so schnell wie ich über 40 Kilometer.
Das ist so krass, Alter. Das ist brutal.
Man hat, wenn man das selbst noch nicht ausprobiert hat, gar keine Vorstellung davon, wie schnell die sind.
Man sieht das daran.
Also ich glaube, jeder, der mal, was weiß ich, olympische Spiele geguckt hat, sich da den Marathon angeguckt hat,
jedem wird, glaube ich, klar sein, dass sie schnell sind.
Weil sonst wären sie nicht bei den olympischen Spielen und wären nicht die Besten auf der Welt, ja?
Aber jemand, der das noch nicht selbst probiert hat, mal so schnell zu rennen, der hat da gar kein Gefühl vor.
Ja, die Leute wissen, ey, die sind schnell.
Aber man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie schnell die sind.
Die sind so, das ist brutal schnell.
Das ist unmenschlich schnell.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja, und was auch krass ist beim Ironman, die schwimmen ja erstmal 3,8 Kilometer.
Dann wird, glaube ich, 180 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren und danach wird nochmal ein Marathon gerannt.
Und die rennen den Marathon auch teilweise in zweieinhalb Stunden.
Also die rennen den mit, keine Ahnung,
drei, drei, ja,
also ungefähr,
die rennen den Marathon so schnell beim Triathlon,
wie ich mit Inlineskates gefahren bin.
WTF?
Und das, und das nach 3,8 Kilometer
schwimmen, 180 Kilometer Fahrradfahren.
Das ist alles nicht mehr normal, ey.
Das ist wirklich abgedreht.
so
nein nein nein habe ich nicht habe ich nicht also das ist wirklich muss jetzt
einfach mal sagen das ist wirklich krass die leute das ist wirklich richtig
brutal und ich habe schon ein paar mal erzählt ich gucke eigentlich ganz gerne
Radsport so nebenbei. Das finde ich
super beruhigend, nebenbei laufen zu lassen.
Leider ist es schwierig
zu gucken, weil du brauchst
irgendwelche Abos.
Was ganz gut ist mit VPN.
Weil in den Ländern, wo die jeweiligen Rennen
stattfinden, die gibt es meistens kostenlose
Streams. Muss aber halt in dem Land
sein offiziell. Da kann man ganz gut
gucken.
Mittlerweile
so internationale Sachen,
so Tour de France und sowas, das wird auch im deutschen
Fernseher übertragen. Leider kann ich
mir das Commentary von denen nicht anhören, ey.
Also der eine ist ja okay, aber der andere
tut alles. Kann ich... Das ist grausam,
das Commentary. Zumindest schade,
schade aktuell,
dass Tour de France so langweilig
ist, weil
Pogacar halt so der Beste aller Zeiten
ist. Wenn der nicht dabei
wäre, wäre das mega spannend,
weil die anderen sind total eng zusammen.
Aber so
ist halt irgendwie
langweilig, ja.
Weißt, es geht berghoch, ah ok
Sieger steht fest, so
Das ist echt langweilig, so
Aber ansonsten ist halt krass, was die da abliefern
War die ursprüngliche Idee von einem Marathon
Nicht so, dass irgendein Kerl in der Antike
42 Kilometer gerannt ist
Um Leute vor Angriff zu warnen
Nee, der ist nicht, um die Leute vor einem Angriff zu warnen
Der ist zurückgelaufen
Um zu sagen, dass sie gewonnen haben
Oder?
Zumindest sagt das die Legende so
der ist zurückgelaufen
und genau, hat gesagt,
dass sie gewonnen haben und das ist er umgekippt
vor Erschöpfung.
Ob das wirklich so war?
Keine Ahnung, ja.
Na war es es nicht.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, wo man GitHub trennt.
AI, AI, AI.
Wo haben die jetzt mittlerweile eigentlich den Knopf für Trends?
War doch nicht blöd, wo ist denn der Knopf für Trends hin?
Ich brauch den nicht, ich hab's in meiner History.
Aber wo ist denn offiziell der Knopf jetzt?
Ressourcen?
Solutions?
Open Source?
Trending?
Okay, schauen wir mal, was die Woche trendet.
Anti-AI-Slob-Design-Skill.
Okay.
Es ist ein Anti-AI-Slob für AI-Slob.
Alles klar.
Okay, KI.
KI.
Denke ich mal zumindest, dass es KI ist.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Open Source Video Editor.
Try early beta.
Was?
Ist das webbasiert oder was?
Ach, das ist ein webbasierter Video Editor.
Bestimmt mit KI, oder?
AI?
Bestimmt auch AI.
AI.
C++-Stells hatten wir schon mal.
Und wahrscheinlich auch AI.
Geil.
Die Trends diese Woche sind wieder kürzer, oder?
Schwankt das immer?
So wie immer.
Ist jetzt nicht so viel Spannendes dabei.
Was trendet denn bei Go?
AI.
TypeScript Go?
Hat das jemand von euch verfolgt?
Gibt es jetzt eigentlich schon ein offizielles
TypeScript Release
mit dem
Go Compiler?
Gucken wir mal.
Ne, anscheinend noch nicht.
Anscheinend noch nicht.
Pocket Base?
Was ist das?
Wie wäre es mit Summershare?
SCP?
Ist das HFS?
So hundertprozentig check ich's noch nicht.
Okay.
Hat bestimmt seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Ich bin einfach zu low IQ, das zu kapieren.
Der Google Maps Craper.
Aha.
AI.
Warten wir schon mal.
AshyCorp Vault.
Würdest du sagen, dass Hochschulabschlüsse in der Industrie helfen?
Also aktuell würde ich sagen, das was mit den Mitabstand am meisten in der Industrie hilft, ist Berufserfahrung.
Terraform Provider AWS.
Okay, New Air.
nicht ein notification kennen wir auch schon paski lima das ist quasi der vm
champion besser ai agcd exzellent go language library for reading and writing
Microsoft Excel-Files.
Okay.
Das ist für Business Enterprise
News.
Tailscale und Terraform.
Ja, okay, bei Go ist das immer nicht ganz so viel
AI-Kram.
Komm, sind wir mal mutig.
Gucken wir mal, was bei TypeScript so trendet.
Bis denn.
Codex, Plugin, CC.
AI, AI, WebKit.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Keine Ahnung.
AI.
ATMX.
Hier klingt jetzt alles nicht sonderlich spannend.
Ähm, was?
Okay, da trennt meistens nichts Sonderliches Spannendes.
Nee, Rust hatten wir noch nicht.
Office CLI, das hatten wir auch schon.
Das hatten wir auch schon. Das hatten wir auch...
Ne, das hatten wir...
Das hatten wir noch nicht.
Ja, C-Sharp ist immer super langweilig.
Was ist das?
China-Chinesen-Kram?
Auch nicht so spannend. Was ist das?
Save Discord Chatlogs to file.
Aha.
Was machen die Krustentiere?
AI.
JavaScript.
Jetzt in Rust.
Früher in SIG.
Da gab es ja auch ein bisschen hin und her Drama.
Screenpipe.
AI.
Postgres Rewrite in Rust.
Moment.
Es gibt ein Postgres Rewrite in Rust?
Das ist doch garantiert Vibe-Coded as fuck, oder?
Ich seh's da unten schon, ja.
AI, UV für Python-Stells.
Python-Linter.
Regram, Cube-Sandbox.
AI.
Text-Editor.
kalt auf kater web server new shell ein counter strike 2 offset damper was auch
immer man sich darunter vorstellen darf
keine ahnung auch keine ahnung was ist zu high iq für mich aber gucken wir doch
mal was soll das sein ach so
Ein Verzeichnis mit Unternehmen, die einen guten Hiring-Prozess haben.
Na gut, das interessiert uns jetzt nicht wirklich.
Qgo-Music.net, China-Chinesen-Gram.
Ah ja, ja.
Ein Anime-Music-Player oder sowas in der Richtung.
Man hat keine Ahnung.
Source.
Es ist in C-Sharp programmiert, oder?
Excellent.
PG Rust.
Postgres Rewrite in Rust.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ey.
Wie viele Comets sind da von Cloud?
Ganz schön viel, würde ich sagen.
Das ist, glaube ich, komplett...
Das ist komplett gevibe-coded, hä?
Okay.
Okay, es ist not ready.
Das ist so ein Rust-Rewrite, wo ich mich echt frage wieder.
Genauso wie bei den Core-Utils.
Warum?
Weil Postgres ist so perfectly fine.
Tested und unreliable.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch wieder so ein Ding, um zu zeigen, was man mit KI alles Geiles machen kann.
Guckt ihr mal an, wie viele Lines per Comet.
Viele wahrscheinlich.
Naja, ne, geht.
Gibt es überhaupt einen Rust-Rewrite, der Sinn ergibt?
naja, es gibt schon ein paar ganz
coole Rust Rewrites.
Die benutze ich aber aus anderen Gründen nicht.
Ja, also es gibt
ein
LS Rewrite in Rust zum Beispiel,
der ganz nice ist.
Zum Beispiel
sowas hier, ja.
LS Rewrite in Rust,
der hat
ein gescheites Highlighting,
kann die Rechte besser anzeigen.
Ist schon ganz nice.
Hat aber auch ein paar andere Optionen.
Benutze ich genau aus dem Grund nicht.
Wenn ich mich jetzt hier dran gewöhne,
heißt das im Umkehrschluss wieder,
ich vergesse, wie LS auf dem Server gescheit funktioniert.
Deswegen benutze ich das nicht. Ja, sowas ist auch ganz cool.
Was ich auch vom Ansatz her
eigentlich ganz nice finde, ist das hier.
Ein Cat-Klon.
Cat-Nachbau mit Syntax-Highlighting
zum Beispiel, ja.
Es gibt schon mal ganz coole Sachen in Rust.
Aber ich benutze sie halt nicht, weil ich dann vergesse, wie die ursprünglichen Tools funktionieren.
Also es gibt aber coole Rust-Software, gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich meine halt so diese Rewrite-Geschichten.
Was ich halt überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann, ist...
Moment, ich muss mal kurz die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Äh, Core Utils Rust Rewrite.
Jo, danke. Wie gesagt, ich sehe das gar nicht, dass ich Partner Anniversary habe.
Was ich halt gar nicht verstehe, ist diese Geschichte hier.
Ja, Cross-Plattform Rust Rewrite of GNU Core Utils.
Die Core Utils, das ist so eines der mit Abstand am meistverwendetsten und meistgetestesten Stücke Software,
die es gibt.
Und ich glaube,
ich hatte trotzdem bisher noch nie
das Gefühl, oh Mist,
die sind ja in C programmiert,
werden die mal in Rust programmiert,
da wäre das alles viel besser.
Weil ganz ehrlich, die Core-Utils,
sei es jetzt so Dinge wie Crep,
Seed, Feind,
LS,
und was da nicht sonst noch alles drin ist,
der Kram funzt, der Kram ist schnell,
der Kram macht nahezu
alles, was man irgendwie braucht.
Also den Rust, den verstehe
ich nicht, den Rust Rewrite.
Aber es ist okay, kann man
machen. Was ich noch weniger
verstehe ist, dass Ubuntu
darauf jetzt schon
umstellen will, obwohl
das noch überhaupt nicht die ganzen Kinderkrankheiten
los ist. Ja, Ubuntu
hat sich letztens, letztens
beispielsweise ihren eigenen Bildprozess wohl
kaputt gemacht. Da gab es keine Ubuntu
Daily Images, wegen
irgendeinem Bug in so
Rust Rewrite Core Utils. Also
das ist ein Projekt.
Ich verstehe das Projekt nicht
und ich verstehe nicht, warum Ubuntu das verwendet.
Ich checke es einfach nicht.
Ja, gegen Rust habe ich
nicht. Rust ist eine super Sprache.
Aber das checke ich wirklich nicht.
Talos Linux.
Ist Talos Linux dieses
Kubernetes, dieses
Kubernetes Distro?
Diese Immutable Kubernetes-Distro?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ja?
Habe ich keine Meinung zu, weil ich es noch nicht ausprobiert habe.
Ich habe eine kleine Meinung dazu.
Das, was ich bisher drüber gelesen habe,
fand ich eigentlich richtig nice.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber als Kubernetes-Node-Distro
finde ich so ein Immutable-Distro
eigentlich ziemlich nice,
weil
du da viel einfacher Nodes
aufbauen und abreißen kannst. Also schneller
und einfacher Nodes abbauen und besser
scalen kannst.
Brauchst du halt
irgendwas drunter, was das macht.
Also brauchst du irgendeine Virtualisierungsplattform oder so.
Aber an sich finde ich das
vom Ansatz her nicht verkehrt.
Aber generell
ist Kubernetes vom Scratch aufbauen
und selbst betreiben ein bisschen
eklig. Brauchst du Kubernetes im
Homelab? Nö.
Habe ich auch nicht vor. Ich habe auf der Arbeit
genug Kubernetes.
Rancher.
Ich habe das mal irgendwann benutzt.
Vor vier Jahren, fünf Jahren.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Als das noch irgendein so ein komisches Desktop
Tool gewesen ist.
Ich habe damals auch schon den Sinn nicht so
ich von verstanden und ich habe mal ich benutze für meine lokalen kubernetes
test einfach immer mini cube und gut ist zum einfachsten und für alles andere
plötzlich irgendwie manager kubernetes und dementsprechend benutze ich das auch
nicht privat weil mir das viel zu teuer ist privaten manager kubernetes zu
kaufen ich glaube am preis leistungstechnik
besten bist du da immer noch bei digital ocean oder sowas die haben ja relativ
schwingliche kubernetes cluster glaube ich zumindest dass die mit dass das das
war das letzte mal wo ich geguckt habe waren die preis leistungsmäßig ganz okay
ich mache mal kurz hier achtung flash bang jetzt da das pricing will ich
eigentlich gucken pricing rising storage compute network compute ob er nicht ist
ja der simple manager kubernetes dass das dass das geht noch halbwegs ja
also wie gesagt bezahlt sie halt pro note dann auch aber dass das geht noch
Bei Google bezahlst du dich da dumm und dämlich.
Sehe ich auf der Arbeit immer.
Ich habe deine KDE-Taskbar genauso konfiguriert.
Hast du ja auch recht, diese CPU.
Hast du auch recht, diese CPU-Anzeige.
Hey.
Der scheint sich irgendwie so intuitiv so ein bisschen anzubieten, ne?
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, ich benutze kaum Sachen von KDE, also kaum Features von KDE.
Ich habe einfach das genauso, also ich komme ja von einem Tiling Window Manager.
Und ich hatte meinen Tiling Window Manager halt exakt genauso eingerichtet.
Auf dem ersten Desktop Browser im Fullscreen, auf dem zweiten Desktop Terminal im Fullscreen,
auf dem dritten Desktop Editor im Fullscreen, auf dem vierten Desktop vielleicht auch nochmal Editor im Fullscreen.
und das habe ich auch und die einzige anwendung wo ich wo ich wirklich teilen gebraucht hätte
oder das beziehungsweise wo ich teilen benutzt habe war mein terminal aber das hat teilen eingebaut
das heißt ich eigentlich habe ich nur noch anwendungen im fullscreen laufen auch unter
kd deswegen ist es für mich nahezu keine umgewöhnung gewesen vom teilen window manager auf kd
ja kde ist nice also ich bin der meinung kde ist mit abstand wirklich mit riesenabstand die
beste desktop so wie man das desktop environment unter linux kde funst einfach kde ist anpassbar
genug dass du teilweise ein bisschen zu viel anpassbar kannst du so einstellen wie du willst
und kde wo ich das noch mal an der stelle zeigen kde hat natürlich das wichtigste feature aller
Zeiten Wobbly Windows.
Das heißt, wenn man
mal Windows movt, dann
sollen sie gefälligst auch Wobbly sein.
Kann man eigentlich die
Wobbliness noch einstellen?
Mal gucken.
Pass auf,
Wobbliness.
Wobbly Windows, kann man die einstellen?
Less?
Wobbliness!
Apply.
Wow, Leute!
Wie es...
Alter!
Wie es wobbelt!
Komm, wie es wobbelt.
Manchmal ist die Wobblin jetzt ein bisschen kaputt.
Es wobbelt.
240 Hertz wobbeln.
Also bei mir ist KDE noch nicht einmal gecrashed.
Wobbeln und dann noch transparent.
Was haben wir?
Enable Advanced Mode.
Stiffness.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich mach den Advanced Mode wieder aus.
Und die wobbeln das wieder runter.
Sonst dreh ich ja hier noch durch.
transparent alle ist schon als ich merke gerade ich hab ich hab mein fenster
schließen noch gar nicht gar nicht konfiguriert wie ich das mache windows
taste gedrückt halten windows taste gedrückt halten und
verschieben und mit der rechten maustaste kannst du sie reessen
ja windows taste gedrückt halten und du kannst rechte maustaste resizen
mittlere maustaste moven ich muss übrigens auch mein fenster
close key bindings wie kann man das einstellen
shortcuts
äh, close,
hallo,
close,
window, window management,
alt F4,
input,
meta shift Q,
bam, so muss das sein, das bin ich nämlich
noch von I3 gewöhnt,
jetzt kann ich endlich meine Fenster hier wieder ordentlich
zumachen, yes,
settings,
bam,
sehr gut,
So, jetzt wurde man ein bisschen sidetracked.
Unter Wayland streamst du von Linux aus.
Das ist unter Wayland.
Aber ich streame nicht von Linux aus.
Mein Setup, da hast du was angesprochen.
Immer wenn ich mein Setup zeige,
verwirrt das gefühlt 80% des Chats so sehr,
dass die Leute Fragezeichen über dem Kopf haben.
Also mein Setup zum Streamen ist folgendermaßen.
Das muss, alle paar Streams muss ich das zeigen, weil ich feiere mein Setup.
Also ich habe folgendes, ich habe folgendes Setup.
Ich streame nicht, ich streame nicht unter Linux.
Guck, du siehst, ich habe hier kein OBS oder irgendwas auf.
Ich streame unter Windows.
Hier, OBS.
OBS unter Windows am Start.
Damit streame ich.
Und hier habe ich mein Linux.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie funktioniert das so nice?
Windows hier und Linux hier und alles auf dem gleichen Monitor und überhaupt und sonst was.
Wie geht das?
Zumal ich sogar hier Overlays und sowas anzeigen lassen kann.
Wie funktioniert das?
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Wenn man es mal gesehen hat, ist das viel weniger Magic als man denkt.
Also ich zeige euch das mal.
Ich habe mehrere Windows-Desktops.
Ich habe Desktop 1.
Da ist Windows drauf.
Also virtuelle Windows-Desktops.
Das kommt bei mir nicht ins Spiel.
NordVPN hat von mir verlangt,
dass ich Videos lösche,
wo ich mich negativ über
VPN-Anbieter geäußert habe,
damit sie
mit mir quasi irgendwas machen.
Bei mir kommt kein NordVPN.
Dafür war ich noch nie in einer Wüste.
Also ich kann auch Cell-Outfence sein.
Ich habe
zwei Desktops.
Windows, also virtuelle Windows-Desktops.
Ein Desktop für Windows,
ein Desktop für Linux,
ein Desktop für
extra Zeug.
So, unter Windows schaltet man die virtuellen
Desktops durch mit
Control-Windows-Taste und dann
Pfeiltaste links-rechts.
Guckt, ihr seht, ich kann hier die
Desktop durchschalten.
So, und jetzt habe ich folgendermaßen
gemacht. Auf dem
zweiten Windows-Desktop, auf den ich
jetzt mal drauf switche, hier,
Ihr seht, ich bewege jetzt nicht, ihr seht meinen Deluxe, aber ich bewege die Windows-Maus und Tastatur, ist ein OBS im Fullscreen.
Ich habe hier einen Mini-PC.
Ich habe hier einen Mini-PC mit einem 8-Kern Ryzen und einer AMD-Grafikkarte.
Und dieser Mini-PC, der steckt in einer Elgato Capture Card.
Ich habe eine PCI Express, Elgato PCI Express Capture Card.
Und das wird gecaptured, ihr seht es hier, zack, Elgato 4K Pro.
Das captured den Output von meinem Linux PC.
Das heißt, ich habe auf dem zweiten Desktop einfach nur Linux im Fullscreen unter Windows laufen.
Ja, also mit OBS.
Und dann ist hier halt mein Linux drauf.
Hast du dann zwei Tastaturen und Mäuse?
Ne, habe ich nicht, das kommt jetzt gleich
Das Ganze funktioniert
nahezu ohne Input-Lag
sowohl was Sound als auch was
Grafik-Ausgabe angeht
Ich bin da sehr empfindlich, das wisst ihr ja
Wenn es irgendwie tiert, laggt
sonst was, drehe ich am Rad
Das ist nahezu native
Also obwohl die
Maus und Tastatur einmal übers Netzwerk muss
Obwohl das er einmal
durch Capture-Karten OBS durch muss
Es ist kein Unterschied. Ich merke keinen Unterschied zu Native hier beim Tippen und bei der Mausbewegung und allem.
Es ist echt kein Unterschied. Also du merkst das nicht.
Ich glaube, wir haben das mal getestet. Wir haben mal so einen Reaktionstest gemacht.
Ich glaube, ich hatte 30, 20 oder 30 Millisekunden unterschiedliche Reaktionszeit.
Also das ist jetzt, ich würde natürlich da keine Competitive Games drauf spielen auf der Liedungskiste,
aber für normales Desktop-Bedienen ist es vollkommen ausreichend.
warum nur full hd weil ich selbst ein full hd bildschirm ich will lieber mehr fps oder
mehr herz als größeren bildschirm so so funktioniert die grafik ausgabe jetzt
natürlich die große preisfrage wie funktioniert das umschalten von maus und tastatur das umschalten
von Maus und Tastatur funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ich habe hier ein Programm laufen, das nennt sich
Deskflow. Deskflow,
das ist im Prinzip ein bisschen sowas wie Synergy,
falls ihr das noch von früher kennt.
Damit kann man Maus und Tastatur,
ja, mittlerweile gibt es das. Als ich mein Monitor
gekauft habe, gab es keine noch, keine
1044p 240 Hertz.
Aber mittlerweile,
ja, also mein nächster Monitor,
was mir so vorschwebt, ist
ein OLED
360 Hertz
so 1044p oder irgendwie sowas.
Es wird teuer. Es wird auf jeden Fall teuer.
Ja, zumindest, ich habe hier ein Programm
laufen, das nennt sich Deskflow.
Deskflow ist ein bisschen sowas wie Synergy.
Damit kann man Maus und Tastatur sharen
zwischen verschiedenen Computern.
Man sieht das auch hier.
Configure Server. Hier ist mein Windows Desktop.
Hier ist mein Linux Desktop drin eingetragen.
Und ich habe, wenn ich jetzt hier mal umschalte,
wenn ich jetzt hier umschalte, hier habe ich auch
Deskflow laufen.
Also Maus und Tastatur gehen bei mir über Deskflow. Maus und Tastatur hängen an meinem Windows Desktop Rechner und wenn ich hier umschalte den Desktop, dann drückt das im Hintergrund, triggert das ein Makro.
dieses Makro
triggert per Shortcut in
Deskflow das Umschalten
zwischen den Desktops.
Also wenn ich die Taste für auf Windows schalten
drücke, triggert das ein Makro,
was den Shortcut in Deskflow
triggert, um auf Windows Desktop umzuschalten
Maus und Tastatur. Wenn ich das andere
drücke, triggert das ein Makro, ihr seht es ja auch,
ihr seht es kurz flimmern immer hier, ne, mit der Maus
und Tastatur.
Triggert das in
Deskflow
einen Shortcut,
dass es auf Linux umschaltet
und dann drückt es halt noch dieses Desktop
umschalten zwischen Windows und Linux.
Und das,
so sieht es aus.
Warum keine Windows-VM?
Oh, das ist abfuck. Das ist abfuck.
Du brauchst eine zweite Grafikkarte,
du brauchst hier, das ist ja im Prinzip ein zweiter
Rechner, ja? Du brauchst eine zweite Grafikkarte,
du brauchst einen zweiten Monitor oder aber
du brauchst sowas wie Looking Glass oder sonst was.
da hätte ich dann wieder Probleme, dass ich denke, wenn ich irgendwas Competitive-mäßiges spiele, es laggt oder sowas.
Zu gibt es auch Spiele, die in der VM einfach nicht richtig funktionieren, weil es sagt, oh, Anti-Cheat, sonst was.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Das ist mir viel zu viel Aufwand und viel zu fehleranfällig, Windows in der Linux-VM.
Das geht prinzipiell, ja, ja. Aber das ist mir zu viel gebastelt.
Aber alles mit einem Monitor
Ne, ne, ich hab zwei Monitore
Ich hab zwei Rechner und zwei Monitore
Aber ich hab fürs Arbeiten und Stream
Hab ich einen Monitor und hier nebendran
So neben dieser Seite hier, die seht ihr jetzt natürlich nicht
Ist
Ein zweiter Monitor an einem zweiten Rechner
Den ich zum Vorschau
Vom Stream und so verwende
Oder zum Einblenden von irgendwelchen
Emotes und sowas benutze ich den zweiten Monitor
Ihr seht meine Maus
geht jetzt rüber auf den zweiten Monitor und jetzt drücke ich hier
das Bild zum Einblenden.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, Dualboot ist mir
zu nervig. Deswegen,
für mich persönlich ist das hier das optimale
Setup. Bessere
Setup geht nicht. Ich kann Linux
und Windows komplett gleichwertig
nebeneinander verwenden. Copy-Paste
geht sogar mittlerweile halbwegs
gut.
mit desk flow also kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren das ist top das liegt
aber auch daran warum das für mich das perfekte selber bist ganz einfach
erklärt früher hatte ich immer so früher hatte ich eine vm laufen
früher hatte ich auf dem zweiten desktop immer eine vm workstation vm laufen mit
linux im fullscreen
Und dann habe ich auch immer umgeswitcht, hier über Shortcuts.
Und ich habe die ganze Zeit schon nach einer Möglichkeit gesucht, wie ich...
Guck, das ist jetzt die VM hier im Endeffekt.
Früher hatte ich das die ganze Zeit so, da habe ich halt hier immer umgeschaltet zwischen Windows und Linux.
Aber ich habe die ganze Zeit schon gesucht danach, wie ich die VM durch eine vollwertige Linux-Hardware-Kiste ablösen kann.
und das Setup habe ich jetzt gefunden
ich meine man musste sich dafür eine Elgato Capture Card
kaufen, also das Setup ist jetzt nicht
gerade billig gewesen, aber für mich ist
das perfekte Setup und scheiß, besseres
Setup geht nicht
Linux, Windows komplett
vollwertig nebeneinander und easy
mit einem Tastendruck umschaltbar
und für
Gaming finde ich es halt auch wichtig, dass ich ein Native
Windows habe
und für Linux finde ich es wichtig, dass man alles ausprobieren kann
dass man ein Native Linux hat
also best für mich für mich perfekt ist
ja das ist ja das ist ziemlich um durch
die brust ins auge workaround aber da
funktioniert gut
ja schön wäre es schön wäre es wenn ich
wenn ich multi billionär wäre würde ich
euch jedem 64 gigabyte ram schenken die
jetzt im chat sind damit ich kein
multibillionär wird.
Wie ist das Setup aufgebaut?
Hab ich doch gerade gezeigt.
Oder was meinst du?
Setup ist aufgebaut.
Linux Mini PC geht in die
Capture Card rein. Capture Card steckt
in den PCI Express Slot von meinem Windows Rechner.
Und dann halt hier OBS auf.
DDR5, klar, klar.
64 Gig DDR5.
Ist ganz einfach.
Ihr müsst jetzt einfach alle Prime subscriben.
Und wenn ich dann Multibillionär bin,
kriegt ihr alle RAM.
Überlegt euch mal, das lohnt sich.
Ihr müsst nur 5 Dollar
ausgeben für den Prime Sub
und ihr kriegt, wenn ich Multibillionär bin,
ein 64 Gigabyte RAM Stick.
Das lohnt sich.
Überleg mal hier Preis-Leistung.
Quasi geschenkt.
Läuft auf zwei getrennten Rechnern.
Was meinst du?
Windows und Linux, ja?
Linux läuft auf einem Mini-PC.
Und Windows läuft auf einem Desktop-PC.
Guck hier.
Hier, Linux.
Und Windows hier auf meinem Desktop-PC.
desktop pc ist kann ich dir zeigen
desktop pc ist der hier
mach einfach mehr sellout ich mache das hier just for fun ich mache ich mache ich
viel sellout ich mache immer nur sellout wenn ich im sellout feeling so wenn ich
Ich fühle gerade den Sellout.
Was ist der Desktop-PC hier?
Zu einer Zeit gekauft, als es noch erschwinglich war.
Guckt mal, wie viel mich der RAM jetzt kosten würde.
Allein für den RAM müsste ich mittlerweile 952 Euro ausgeben.
Warum nicht einfach WSL und WSLG fürs Grafische?
Boah, nee.
Da könnte ich kein KDE laufen lassen.
Da könnte ich kein Wobbly Windows laufen lassen.
Ich meine, der Wobbly Windows ist das Wichtigste überhaupt.
Das ist eklig. Ich brauche eine vollständige, vollwertige Linux-Umgebung.
Nicht sowas...
...befnittenes...
...WSL, WSL.
Übrigens, was es jetzt gibt, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind,
es gibt jetzt Core-Utils für Windows, habe ich gesehen.
Guck mal hier, von Microsoft. Das ist jetzt neu.
Was läuft da an Windows? Ganz normal, Windows 11.
Core-Utils für Windows. Installer und Packaging.
Guck mal, es gibt jetzt...
Die haben das kompiliert für Windows.
Was da läuft?
Cache US.
Ist das.
Cache US Arch, by the way.
By the way, das sind doch nicht alle Core-Utils, oder?
Da fehlt Seed.
Da fehlt AWK.
Ist AWK überhaupt Core-Utils?
Ich glaube schon.
Da fehlt doch die Hälfte.
Da fehlt doch die Hälfte
an Core-Utils.
Ne, benutze ich nicht.
Moment, jetzt die wichtigsten Sachen fehlen da ja.
Ist da überhaupt Crep dabei?
Da ist doch nicht mal Crep dabei.
Ja, was ist das für ein unsinniger Kack?
cmd habe ich früher oft benutzt
kde funds aber bestimmt nicht mit wobbly windows außerdem brauche ich ein
vollständiges linux darunter vollständiges archlinux ich habe keinen
bock mich mit irgendwelchen windows sachen unter linux rum zu ärgern
Nee, nee.
Mit WSL...
kann er es nicht ersetzen.
Kannst du das empfehlen?
CashOS? Ja.
Kommt ein bisschen drauf an.
Also wenn du kompletter Einsteiger bist,
kann man das machen,
wenn man sehr interessiert ist und viel lernen will.
Aber als reines Einsteigersystem,
wenn es dir rein ums Benutzen geht.
Wenn du sagst, ey, ich will ein System installieren,
mich nicht so sehr mit Linux
beschäftigen, sondern es halt quasi
eher rein anwendermäßig
für meine täglichen Aufgaben
nutzen und die sind jetzt nicht so anspruchsvoll,
dann würde ich vielleicht
nicht unbedingt mit CacheOS, weil da ist immer noch eine Art
Linux unten drunter.
Also, dann würde ich
vielleicht gucken, dass ich mir,
wenn es um Gaming geht, dass ich mir irgendwie Nubara
oder irgendwie sowas installiere, keine Ahnung.
Aber CacheOS kann man auch gut als Einstiegssystem benutzen, das funzt schon.
CacheOS finde ich ist halt ein super Einstiegssystem für alle, die sich ein bisschen mit Linux beschäftigen wollen.
Weil du hast ein vollständiges Arch Linux drunter, mit allem was dazu gehört.
Du kannst alles super krass customizen, so wie es geht.
Du kannst auf das Arch Wiki zurückgreifen, aber du hast halt trotzdem ein gut eingerichtet,
vorkonfiguriertes Standard KDE Desktop System.
Ja, Linux Mint ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
also ich finde ich finde es nice und es hat den vorteil wenn du kerstin erst benutzt dann lernst
du halt automatisch auch ein bisschen linux weil im stream kommt ihr öfters die frage auf max ich
will mich jetzt mit die luchs beschäftigen was mache ich da am besten ja und die leute fangen
dann meistens an mit HomeLab, Raspberry Pi, Mini PC, sonst was.
Und mein Tipp, wenn man wirklich erstmal so das Feeling bekommen möchte für Linux,
ist das Beste, was man machen kann, sich Linux zu installieren auf Mini PC oder in einer
VM.
Kein Dualboot oder irgendwie so ein Geschiss.
Man sollte sich seine alte Arbeitsumgebung einfach eins zu eins so erhalten wie das.
Man kauft sich einen Mini PC oder man installiert sich eine VM mit Linux und dann versucht man
einfach die nächsten monate seine tägliche arbeit unter linux zu
erledigen und da wirst du dich zwangsläufig damit beschäftigen müssen
okay wie installiere ich pakete nach wie konfiguriert kde ein bisschen wie
bewege ich mich auf der kommandozeile und dann werden ja die unterschiede
auffallen zwischen windows und linux und dann kommst du rein und nach einem
halben jahr kannst du dich sicher und gut unter linux bewegen und dann wenn du
dann technisch noch ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen willst und dann dich mit
sagen wir mal, irgendwelchen Server-Sachen
beschäftigen willst, dann kannst du den Raspberry Pi kaufen
oder noch einen zweiten Mini-PC oder
mal Docker installieren und ein bisschen
Zeug programmieren, Docker-Files erstellen
und so, dann kannst du damit anfangen. Aber
man sollte sich erst mal, finde ich zumindest,
ein bisschen
so bekannt machen mit Linux und das ist am besten
einfach, indem man einen eigenen Mini-PC mit Linux
drauf hat oder eben eine 4M.
4M habe ich euch ja gerade gezeigt,
habe ich ja auch jahrelang verwendet.
Ja, siehst du.
Was? Standard auf KDE installieren?
Testrechner?
Wie jetzt?
Also ich würde kein ULBoot oder so machen.
Ich würde einfach
einen günstigen Mini-PC kaufen.
Oder aber, nachdem RAM gerade so teuer ist,
vor allem,
vor allem, weil Workstation ist mittlerweile kostenlos.
Vor allem, weil Workstation kostet nichts mehr.
VirtualBox geht aber auch genauso gut.
Ja, Manjaro habe ich auch eine ganze Weile verwendet.
Ich habe einen alten Testrechner für Linux.
Oh ja.
Kannst du nehmen.
Linux ist da nicht so anspruchsvoll.
Ich meine, ein bisschen RAM und ein paar CPU-Kameras, was ist das für ein alter Testrechner?
Was ist denn da drin?
Also wenn es jetzt, keine Ahnung, ein Pentium 3 mit 256 MB RAM ist, dann würde ich das jetzt nicht unbedingt machen.
Aber wenn das was halbwegs aktuelles, so aus dem letzten Jahrzehnt ist, dann geht das vermutlich problemlos klar.
Max, nutzt ihr auf der Arbeit? Nein, wir haben kein BSD am Start.
Warum bist du nicht komplett auf Linux?
Naja, ich mach's halt so, ich benutze die Sachen auf Linux, die für Linux gut sind und die Sachen unter Windows, die für Windows, sagen wir mal, besser sind.
Ja, also wenn es um Videos erstellen geht, wenn es um Thumbnails erstellen geht, wenn es um Sache spielen geht, vielleicht noch was mit Anti-Cheat, dann unter Windows, ansonsten alles andere unter Linux.
zum internetbrowser benutze ich beispielsweise auch zum größten teil linux weil da ist die
chance dass du dir irgendwas einfängst halt viel geringer als unter windows ich meine unter windows
würde ich prinzipiell gar nicht mehr ins internet gehen ohne you blog origin aber selbst dann weißt
du unter windows nie und unter linux unter windows nie unter linux mache ich mir jetzt nicht so viele
gedanken linux firefox u blog origin gutes
ein i5 8 gb ja ja das funktioniert das funktioniert beim mini pc bei der way
dann auch nur 8 gb ram und da sogar ein bisschen weniger weil die grafikkarte
noch mal abzwackt
Arch als Base und CacheOS Repro Suit kann man auch machen, klar.
Aber ich finde CacheOS zum Einstieg nicht verkehrt, weil du halt ein gescheit vorkonfiguriertes KDE kriegst.
Ja, Grafikkarte ist erstmal nicht so wichtig, wobei man prinzipiell sagen muss,
Nvidia Grafikkarten sind nicht so geil unter Linux,
wobei ich glaube, die ganz alten werden noch besser supportet, weil die vom Open Source Driver supportet werden als die neuen.
Wissen tue ich es nicht, wie gut die Grafikkarten sind.
Da würde ich mich vorher tatsächlich mal schlau machen, wie gut die funzen unter Linux.
So.
Haben wir eigentlich jetzt alles durchgeguckt, was auf GitHub trendet?
Ich glaube schon, ne?
Ja, ja, haben wir.
Haben wir durch.
Schauen wir mal, was gibt es denn
auf YouTube heute so?
Mir wird es kühl, ich muss so die Klimaanlage ausmachen.
Irgendwie ist das nervig.
Vorher hatte ich hier 28,5 Grad.
Jetzt habe ich die Klimaanlage
auf 26 Grad eingestellt.
26,2.
Und irgendwie ist es mir jetzt zu kühl.
Ich meine, das sind 2,5 Grad Unterschied.
KDE
Das Standard Desktop bei Casio ist KDE
Plasma
Heißt das im Installer dann
Wo ich bin?
In Frankfurt
Aber wenn ich Fenster aufmache, kommt auch deutlich kühler rein
Also eigentlich bin ich dumm
Dass ich die Klimaanlage anmache und nicht das Fenster auf
So ist es halt.
Erschreckt mich nicht so Morpheus.
Gibt es hier irgendwas Spannendes, was wir gucken können?
174 Millionen GmbH-Verkauf.
Ja, genau.
Das ist...
Also die
Videoempfehlungen sind ja heute ziemlich
keck-weight.
Die Wahrheit über Incocti.
Was Datenlöscherdienste dir nicht erzählen.
Okay.
Ich hab da jetzt öfters Werbung zugesehen.
Ich hab das schon immer
so mit nem...
Wie soll man sagen, mit so einem Stirnrunzeln immer mir angeguckt, diese Werbung, so nach dem Motto, das soll wirklich funktionieren?
290 Euro im Jahr. Das ist der Preis, den...
Inkogni.
...Inkogni für seinen Service verlangt. Das sind 24 Euro im Monat, dann kümmern die sich um meine Daten.
Oder so. Die Frage ist nur, was kriegst du eigentlich dafür? Also wirklich.
wahrscheinlich nicht viel wahrscheinlich kriege ich ein bisschen ein bisschen
spam von denen wo die mir zeigen was sie tolles aufgeräumt haben um wirklichkeit
ist nicht allzu viel passiert
es gab da ein video ist die us-bau weil ich mir aber ich habe so viele tabs auch
habe ich das hier noch
was
c++ sorry wts kann mir angucken
Ich hab jetzt eher Bock.
Wir gucken jetzt. Da hab ich Bock drauf.
Was die Leute mit der Heimautomatisierungstechnik
gebaut haben. Das guck ich immer gerne.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
29 Minuten, so wie ich mich kenn, dauert das
jetzt auch wieder eine Stunde oder so, bis wir da durch sind.
Die offizielle
Java-Dokumentation.
Ja, übertreibt halt.
Zorin OS? Nee, auf gar keinen Fall.
Menschentiere Automationen oder sowas, würde ich jetzt gleich sagen.
Das war doch eine Smartwatch.
Moment, wir brauchen hier höhere Auflösung.
Aber was dann? Was dann, Maximilian?
Ich habe...
Was?
Chat, er sieht mich.
Erwischt.
Leute, jede Menge kostenlose Sensoren für dein Smart Home, finde ich.
Die sind besser als die, die du hast.
Die sind besser gewartet als deine.
und damit kannst du Dinge umsetzen, die du alleine gar nicht hinbekommen kannst.
Denn heute schauen wir uns genau solche Automationen an,
die kostenlose öffentliche Sensoren in deiner Nähe mit deinem...
Da habe ich auch was.
Da habe ich auch mal was ausprobiert bei mir daheim mit kostenlosen öffentlichen Sensoren.
Das habe ich aber nie in Betrieb genommen.
Ich bin mir schon gar nicht mehr sicher, wie es heißt.
Ich habe mir mal so einen Funkstick gekauft.
ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt,
S...
SD irgendwas?
So ein Funkstick?
Ne, nicht LoRaWAN.
SDR!
SDR, das meine ich, ja.
So ein Funkstick gekauft,
der eigentlich gar nicht dafür gedacht war
und mit einer Software
ausgelesen,
was für Sensoren so hier
funken.
Und
da habe ich einiges gefunden tatsächlich.
Da habe ich
so Wetterstationen
gefunden, Temperaturensensor.
Also da gab es tatsächlich einiges
hier in der Umgebung.
Habe ich dann aber nie in Betrieb genommen, weil ich mir gedacht habe,
ey, du kannst ja nicht wirklich darauf verlassen, dass die Dinger da bleiben.
So, aber mal gucken,
was hier erst drankommt.
Ich komme nie wieder zu spät zur Arbeit, schone die Füße deines Hundes, stehe nie wieder vor einer vollen Packstation und habe im Sommer immer die kühlste Wohnung von allen.
Wir gehen direkt rein.
Menschentiere-Automation, Sonderfolge, die Stadt ruft.
Ich zeige euch hier mal meinen Gassi-Orakel, welches ich mit Hilfe der Sensoren der Stadt...
Was? Ach, Gassi-Orakel.
...gebaut habe.
Ein Gassi-Orakel.
Angefangen hier mit der Profilauswahl, also was für einen Hund habe ich, einen kleinen, mittleren oder einen großen.
Kleine Hunde sind natürlich ein bisschen empfindlicher und näher am Boden.
Größere Hunde haben größere Vor-
Da habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Was ist denn da mit Katzen? Die sind dauergefährdet.
Boden und sind nicht so empfindlich gegenüber Temperatur und auch warm oder heißem Asphalt.
Und genau, dann gehen wir auch schon hier zu den Sensoren über.
Und zwar haben wir ja einmal drei Sensoren, die wir live abfragen.
Einmal den Bodentemperatursensor, einmal den Luftqualitätssensor und einmal den Salzkonzentrationssensor.
Alles drei super spannende Werte für, ich sag mal, Gassi gehen und für unsere...
Okay, verstehe ich, verstehe ich, verstehe ich.
Salzkonzentration ist, wenn die Leute im Winter, wenn die gestreut haben und so,
dass das für die Füße nicht gut ist, habe ich schon öfters immer gelesen.
Der Bodentemperatursensor zeigt an, wie die Fahrbahn gerade ist,
ob man auch wirklich entspannt spazieren gehen kann.
Der Luftqualitätssensor zeigt an, wie die Luft ist, ob der Hund unbeschwert...
Ich habe übrigens auch einen Luftqualitätssensor von Ikea gehabt.
Das Ding hat aber nichts getaucht.
Das war am Anfang okay, wurde dann aber immer ungenauer.
Mittlerweile benutze ich es nicht mehr.
Und der Mensch ja auch.
Also im Zweifel weißt du, ob es eine gute Idee ist, gerade durch die Stadt zu laufen, oder?
Deutlich interessanter, da die noch mal näher am Boden sind und Feinstaub,
so wie die ganzen Abgase sich ja am Boden sammeln.
Und der Streusalz- bzw. der Salzkonzentrationssensor ist halt auch wichtig,
da Pfoten durch Salz auch oft gereizt werden.
und das Ganze habe ich dann in eine Ampellogik unterteilt.
Das heißt, wenn alles grün ist, ist super, gar keine Bedenken.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch hier, ich sage mal, diesen eingeschränkten Status, das heißt orange.
Aber was dann? Was dann, Maximilian? Der Hund muss ja raus.
Und rot heißt natürlich dann komplett.
Dann kriegt er wahrscheinlich Socken angezogen oder sowas, dass er dann nicht mehr drauf rumlaufen muss.
Kritisch, also Asphalt ist zu heiß, man sollte eher Feldwege gehen.
Was man bei deinen Texten auch sieht, es ist viel unnötiger Text mit drin, oder? Also das hast du doch zusammen mit einem KI-Assistenten gewastelt. Nicht, dass das irgendwie relevant wäre.
Und das alles kann man sich dann quasi hier einbauen. Die Sensoren, die hätte ich so quasi nicht abfragen können. Jetzt durch die Station Link habe ich die Sensoren. Das ist natürlich eine super Sache.
Und wie?
Also so hat man immer auf den Blick, wenn man mal gerade nicht weiß, ob es jetzt wirklich zu warm ist.
Das finde ich schon mal ganz interessant. Erstmal, weil es ein Anwendungsfall ist, den ich einfach nicht habe in Ermangelung eines Hundes. Aber da dann gerade, wenn du jetzt vielleicht mehrere Gassi-Routen hast, die auch ranken zu lassen und einfach, dass dein Home Assistant dir sagt, wo du jetzt gefälligst lang gehen sollst, finde ich erstmal ganz interessant. Und wenn es nicht anders geht, halt alles ins Auto und ab in den Wald und dafür sorgen, dass die Feinstaubbelastung für alle anderen noch weiter steigt.
Ich muss fast jeden Tag zur Arbeit und nehme dafür den Bus.
Ein Schicksal, das viele...
Ja und? Wie hat er denn jetzt von der Stadt Solingen die Sensoren gekriegt?
Gibt es die öffentlich oder wie? Oder was?
Das wäre jetzt ja das Interessante gewesen. Wie hat er das denn gemacht?
Menschen teilen.
Will ich fast jeden Tag, irgendwann am Morgen wissen, wann der nächste Bus kommt,
ob er verspätet ist, ob ich rennen sollte oder gleich auf den nächsten warten kann.
Ja, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Das ist auch eine Smartwatch.
Ob er verspätet ist.
Eine super, super smarte Watch.
Das ist ein Widget, das direkt auf der Armbanduhr zeigt, ob der Bus zu spät ist.
Bisher musste ich wie ein Neandertaler erst meine ÖPNV-App öffnen und dann die Zielhaltestelle aus den Favoriten wählen.
Das sind zwei Klicks zu viel.
Besser wäre es, wenn mein Handy weiß, was ich wissen will und mir direkt beim Draufschauen sagt, welche Busse als nächstes kommen und wie spät sie sind.
Ich wusste, dass es eine inoffizielle Integration für meinen lokalen Verkehrsverbund in Home Assistant gibt und habe deshalb die genutzt.
Aha. Moment, Moment. Gibt es sowas für mich auch?
Home Assistant
RMV.
Ah.
Interesting.
Das ist nice.
Gut zu wissen.
Es zeigt standardmäßig,
welcher Bus an meiner Haltestelle als nächstes fährt
und ob er verspätet ist.
Das bringt mir aber nicht immer was, weil die Hälfte der Busse
in die falsche Richtung fährt. Ich habe deshalb die Integration etwas angepasst.
Sie nutzt eher inoffiziell die interne Schnittstelle der elektronischen
Fahrplanauskunft des ÖPNV. Ich habe mir noch eine...
Jetzt bin ich da sehend, warte mal.
What?
Ach, das ist einfach nur Jason schöner dargestellt, oder was?
... des ÖPNV. Ich habe mir noch eine Texteingabe angelegt, mit der ich aus allen Abfahrten genau die rausfiltern kann, die mich zur Arbeit bringen.
Dafür gebe ich jeweils Liniennummer und Richtung an, zum Beispiel 5 Richtung Hauptbahnhof.
Das gefilterte Ergebnis wird in einem Template-Sensor gespeichert.
Außerdem habe ich Zeitangaben, um den Zeitraum zu definieren, in dem ich zur Arbeit losgehe.
So liegen alle Daten bereit, um eine ordentliche Automation zu bauen.
Moment mal, hast du gerade versucht, unterschwellig in den Satz Solingen einzubauen, um dir hier bessere Chancen zu erschleichen?
So liegen alle Daten bereit, um eine ordentliche Automation zu starten.
So liegen, oder?
Meine Automation löst jede Minute aus,
außerdem bei Ende des angegebenen Zeitraums und wenn ich mein Zuhause verlasse.
Im Normalfall wird eine Benachrichtigung an mein Handy geschickt,
die mir zeigt, welche Linien zu welcher Uhrzeit Richtung Arbeit fahren,
wie viele Minuten Restzeit ich habe und ob sie schon verspätet sind.
Die Benachrichtigung hat einen Tag erhalten,
damit nicht jede Minute eine weitere hinzugefügt wird,
sondern die bestehende Benachrichtigung ersetzt werden kann.
Falls die Automation dadurch ausgelöst wird, dass ich mein Zuhause verlasse,
wird die Benachrichtigung auch über diesen Tag gelöscht.
Ich muss sie also nicht wegwischen, wenn ich im Bus sitze.
Die Benachrichtigung habe ich passiv eingestellt,
damit das Handy nicht jede Minute aufleuchtet.
Das ist ja cool.
Also vor allem so eine persistente Benachrichtigung zu benutzen,
um sie zu updaten.
Es ist das Widget des kleinen Mannes
und vor allem eins, das du kontextabhängig zeigen kannst.
Also in diesem Fall...
Also ich benutze immer BahnExpert.
Kennt ihr die Seite?
Die ist eigentlich recht bekannt mittlerweile hier.
Bahn.Expert.
Beste.
Guck hier, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Mal gucken.
So hier, keine Ahnung, da wollen wir hin.
Nein, ich busse hier.
Das da, bam, keine Ahnung.
Was ich bei BahnExpert ganz praktisch finde, ist,
dass ihr nicht nur gucken könnt, ob euer Zug pünktlich ist,
ihr könnt auch gucken, ob der Zug, der quasi auf der Hinfahrt
und dann zu eurem Zug wird, ob der pünktlich ist.
Weil daraus kann man sich viel mehr ableiten,
als das, was die Bahnen bei dem eigentlichen Zug anzeigen.
Also Bahnexpert hier, beste Seite.
Türöffner.
Das ist so eine Art Switch-Bot oder sowas, ja?
Das ist ein kleiner Servomotor.
Der ist analog, damit ich...
Nicht-invasiv ist hier natürlich Auslegungssache.
Also ja, du musst nicht in deine Türklingel irgendwie aufschrauben und irgendwas ranlöten.
Das optische Empfinden ist natürlich schon ein bisschen infiltriert in diesem Fall, oder?
Und er ist in meiner Smart Home App.
Vor allem, weil du für das andere Ding ja auch ein Gehäuse gedruckt hast.
Im Fall ist das HomeKit integriert mittels HomeKit.
Apple stellt es.
Wenn ich hier drücke, dann öffnet es die Tür unten.
Dann ist der Eingang für drei Sekunden.
Weil ich mich frage ist, wie hat er diesen Switch-Bot dahin bekommen, dass der da hält?
Weil wenn das Kleber ist, dann wird das nicht so lange halten.
Kleber ist eigentlich der größte G-Baiter.
Kleber wirkt am Anfang immer so, als wäre das richtig fest.
Aber nach zwei, drei Wochen fällt es dann irgendwann runter.
Am Anfang denkst du immer, ey, boah, das hält ja richtig.
Kleber klappt nicht richtig.
Auf Dauer.
Des Weiteren habe ich hier ein E-Wing Display, was mit einem ESP32 verbunden ist.
Hier sind zwei Stück drin, einmal hierfür und einmal für die Anzeige.
Und eine einzelne Stromversorgung habe ich hier.
Hier habe ich einmal über Open Weather eine lokale Wetterstation abgefragt.
Aber mit einem E-Ink-Display, ne?
Die mir das Wetter in meiner Stadt anzeigt.
Und ich habe die Abfahrtszeiten zum Hauptbahnhof über Fahrplanauskunft Connect angefragt.
Und mir werden 10.000 Anfragen am Tag zur Verfügung gestellt.
Ich kann also mehr als einmal die Minute die Abfahrtszeiten abfragen.
Und hier haben wir jetzt Connect Fahrplanauskunft.
damit arbeiten sehr viele Städte zusammen. Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher, ob alle Städte hiermit zusammenarbeiten.
Aber hier kann man einen Open Service API anfragen, den geben sie einem auch verhältnismäßig schnell.
Ich habe einfach gesagt, wofür ich das benutzen möchte und dann habe ich einen Schlüssel bekommen.
Ich habe aber zudem noch eine Dokumentation bekommen und das war es.
Das war ein bisschen Formelei herauszufinden, welche Kennung meine Haltestelle hat und so weiter.
Da ist gut, wenn man sich da schon ein bisschen mit auskennt und ansonsten hilft ja auch jede KI da weiter.
Und für das Wetter, naja ob die KI jetzt die ID von der Haltestelle weiß, gibt es einem auch wirklich genau für den Standort einen API-Key.
Also ich finde diese ganzen ÖPNV-Sachen schon sehr interessant, vor allem weil ich das bei unserem alten Haus kennengelernt habe. Das war so ein bisschen zwischen drei Bushaltestellen gelegen und das war dann schon immer so ein bisschen die Frage, in welche Richtung gehe ich jetzt allein aus dem Haus, um möglichst schnell dahin zu kommen, wo ich hin will. Und sowas so ein bisschen passiv beim Rausgehen zu machen, finde ich schon sehr cool.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, also ÖPNV-Daten sind was, was überall öffentlich zur Verfügung gestellt werden sollte.
Ich habe jetzt gerade geguckt, bei dem Connecting ist Bremen und auch alles, was für mich relevant wäre, auch der VBN wären mit drin.
Und wenn man da irgendwie ein API-Key für 10.000 Anfragen am Tag kriegt, dann sollte das für so ein Smart Home Dashboard ja schon immer passen.
Und das Gleiche bei der Wettergeschichte. Das wäre natürlich schön, wenn du sogar direkt sehen kannst, welche...
Tja, und wenn Hersteller keine API-Keys verteilen, dann werden die Leute auch so kreativ.
Dann wird dann angefangen zu Webscrapen und sowas.
Und wenn man anfängt zu Webscrapen, sperrt man sich auch ganz schnell mal aus.
Ich spreche da aus Erfahrung.
Ich habe mal, weil das habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal erzählt,
ich habe Domains bei einem Domain-Anbieter, der heißt so.
Ups.
Verdrückt.
Org-Ban, habe ich ein paar Domains.
Und mittlerweile haben die eine
DNS-AP. Also mittlerweile haben sie
irgendwo hier Dokumentation für ihre
DNS-AP, AP-Access und sowas.
Damals hatten die das noch nicht.
Und ich wollte unbedingt
Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate darauf ausstellen.
Das heißt, ich habe es so gemacht,
ich habe mir mit Puppeteer, das ist eine
Browser-Automatisierung, habe ich
das quasi nachgebaut, wie man über das
Web-Interface DNS-Einträge
hinzufügt und so also quasi so hier drauf auf das element klicken und sonst
was und da habe ich dann aber verkackt da habe ich das zu oft ausgeführt und
haben die meine ip geblockt da muss ich dann eine mail hin schreiben und sagen
leute tut mir leid aus versehen zu viel anfragen geschickt haben die auch
gleich zurückgeschrieben ich soll aufhören ihre seite zu skripten
das gefällt ihnen nicht das wollen sie nicht haben und ja ja ok mache ich nicht
nicht wieder, schaltet mich mal wieder frei.
Und dann habe ich aus Versehen
einen Tag später das gleiche
Skript nochmal gestartet und ich war wieder gesperrt.
Da musste ich nochmal
hinschreiben, so, ups, Leute, ich habe mich
vertan.
Da musste ich nochmal freischalten. Aber haben sie auch
gemacht, haben sie gemacht.
Ein bisschen verkackt.
So, jetzt
gucken wir aber weiter.
Wetterstationen da im Zugriff sind,
also dass du dir auswählen kannst, welche, weil ich hatte,
ich habe das bei mir
ein Home Assistant auch noch eingebaut.
Home Assistant!
Weil unsere auf dem Dach halt einfach zu sehr
in der Sonne ist. Also für Temperaturanzeige
ist das Quatsch. Aber die nächste
Wetterstation, die ich, ich habe aber nicht
bei OpenWeb. Also ich habe auch eine eigene
Wetterstation. Das war eines der besten
so Smart Home Anschaffungen, die ich
gemacht habe. Das ist mega praktisch.
Allein schon, dass man, die steht
quasi
zu einer Seite im Hof, im Schatten,
dass wir endlich mal eine richtig gescheite, ordentliche Tastatur anstellen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr welche.
Irgendeine von den günstigen bei Amazon.
Wir haben sogar im Stream dafür was programmiert.
Du müsstest mal im Archiv... Warte mal.
Im Archiv gibt es doch hier Wetterstation.
China Wetterstation.
Ja, das ist das Dashboard davon.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich...
Irgendwo hier im Stream werde ich bestimmt zeigen,
welche Wetterstation das ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Jaja, die läuft schon vier Jahre.
ohne probleme da kommen kommen wieder aufladen wieder auf ladbare batterien
rein und die laden sich über so ein solar panel wieder auf eigentlich
richtig richtig nah ist das ding das war wirklich super super anschaffung also
man sieht man sieht halt da alles mögliche wie hells ist wie viel regen
runterkommen wieder wind ist welche windrichtung wobei das mit dem regen nur
verhältnismäßig gut klappt das zeigt erst ab einer gewissen menge überhaupt
was an also wenn es einfach ein bisschen tröpfelt sieht man das nicht da fehlt
dem so ein Sensor fällt.
Aber an sich ist es nice. Das ist nämlich
eine verlässliche, und das ist das, wofür ich es hauptsächlich
höre, eine verlässliche
Temperaturanzeige,
wie es im Schatten draußen gerade ist.
Also allein schon dafür lohnt sich das.
Guck, muss ich gestehen,
die ist schon ein Stück
weg und auf der anderen Weserseite. Und das ist ja
natürlich, wenn das dann irgendwie
das Wetter da mal an der Kante
unterschiedlich ist, kann das schon mal
ein, zwei Grad Unterschied machen.
Oder Regen oder nicht Regen. Was mir
aber auch deine Einsendung zeigt, ist,
es gibt ziemlich viel.
Es ist nur überall verstreut.
Es wäre natürlich schön, wenn eine Stadt
oder vielleicht sogar das ganze Land
irgendwann sagt, hier sind die Daten.
Nimm sie doch, mach was Schönes.
Das wäre nice, das werden wir
in Deutschland aber wahrscheinlich nicht sehen.
Was Schönes damit machen, womit man noch viel
Schönes machen kann, ist Geld. Weißt du noch,
wann Deutschland das letzte Mal Weltmeister
wurde? Das war 2014
und es fühlt sich gar nicht so lange her an.
Sehr laut.
Das Konto ist in wenigen Minuten schon ordentlich vermehrt.
Mit seinem Rheinpegel-Geschichte hatte ich neulich schon im Video zumindest die Ronno-Steuerung.
Die Rheinpegel-Geschichte habe ich zurückgehalten für das Video heute.
Und zwar wohnen wir in der Nähe des Rheins und ich fand es ganz interessant, da den Rheinpegel von unserer aktuellen Örtlichkeit mit einzubeziehen.
Dementsprechend habe ich hier diese Visualisierung im IO-Broker gebaut und hier sieht man...
Kann mir nicht helfen, aber ich finde IO Broker sieht immer so 1990 aus.
Ist aber gerade in Deutschland sehr beliebt.
Ich hatte auch mal eine Weile einen laufen, weil es da ein paar Integrationen gab, die es nur bei IO Broker gab.
Den monatlichen Verlauf über den Rheinpegelstand, den ich interpoliere für unser kleines Dörfchen.
Und hier auf der rechten Seite alle Werte, die ich direkt auslese.
und nochmal eine Visualisierung, wie hoch der Niederschlag ist.
Hier, dieses Schiff wird auch dementsprechend deaktiviert.
Ja, weil keiner schreibt Material UI.
Ich mag das Home Assistant Material Design jetzt auch nicht so sehr.
Wie jetzt, sofern der Rheinpegelstand so hoch ist,
dass der Schiffsverkehr eingestellt wird
und wir sehen hier noch ein kleines Plätzchen.
Was hat denn der Org damit zu tun?
So hoch oder so niedrig?
Also wird der Schiffsverkehr eingestellt, wenn der Rhein zu hoch ist?
Was wir haben, wo wir uns oftmals hinlegen,
am Rhein, das aber nur erreichbar ist,
wenn ein gewisser Pegelstand unterschritten ist.
Wie habe ich das Ganze implementiert?
Und zwar habe ich über eine Parser-Funktion
die Website Pegel Online dazu genutzt.
Okay, die Website ist auf jeden Fall auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Pegel Online.
Man kann auch mittlerweile über eine Messstellen-UUID das Ganze auslesen. Das ist nochmal für eine nächste Erweiterung von mir dann über einen JSON-File dann geplant. Das Ganze ist im IO-Broker umgesetzt.
MonkaS Blockly.
Anschließend, wie gesagt, muss interpoliert werden. Das mache ich aufgrund der...
By the way, das ist was sehr ähnliches.
Gab es ja in Battlefield 2042 auch.
Rein Kilometer und interpoliere zwischen den erreichbaren Messstellen meinen persönlichen Wert.
Anschließend gibt es noch eine kleine Visualisierung, damit ich den Reinpegelstand gleich mal manipulieren kann,
habe ich hier eine kleine Sonderfunktion jetzt gerade eingebaut, damit wir mal sehen, wie es auf der...
Ich kann den Reihenspiegel jetzt manipulieren.
...bis dann angezeigt wird.
Natürlich werden auch...
Jetzt war es 42, ja?
...Anmeldungen für mich losgelöst, wenn gewisse Pegelstände überschritten werden,
wird das dann per Pushover oder WhatsApp-Nachricht dann an uns geschickt,
dass wir dann darüber informiert werden können.
Das finde ich auch ein ganz spannendes Thema.
das war ja auch bei dem Besuch in Solingen, hier findet ihr das Video, ein Thema. Also für die Städte,
die an Flüssen liegen, die vielleicht mal häufiger ihre Begrenzung verlassen, ist das noch ein sehr
viel relevanteres Ding, dass man dann sagt, okay, es geht jetzt langsam los oder im Prinzip wie ein
Feueralarm im Zweifelsfall will ich auch nachts geweckt werden, wenn hier gerade irgendwie
Hochwasser.
eine Springflut ist.
Eigentlich, gerade wenn man in der Nähe wohnt von einem Fluss, ich wohne jetzt auch nicht so weit weg vom Main, aber höher gelegen, also bei uns ist das kein Problem.
Aber wenn ich da irgendwie ein Haus hätte, was in der Nähe vom Main ist, dann fände ich das auch sehr sinnig.
Pegelstände.
... mir weniger vor Augen führe, wobei auch die Weser vor anderthalb Jahren sich ein bisschen verbreitert hatte.
Dann sehen wir mal, dass dementsprechend hier der Pegelstand erhöht wird.
Normalerweise ist natürlich dieses Diagramm auch damit verbunden und würde das jetzt hier noch mit hochgehen.
Aber wir haben jetzt hier gesehen, dieser Liegestuhl ist deaktiviert worden.
Und wenn es jetzt noch weiter ansteigen würde, würde auch das Schiff verschwinden.
Abschließend vielleicht noch ein kleiner...
Es ist also echt so...
Gut, wenn der Stand zu hoch ist, wird das dann zu schnell?
Warum hört man dann auf mit... Also ich kann verstehen, warum man mit dem Schiff nicht mehr fährt, wenn es zu niedrig ist, weil dann läuft man auf.
Das finde ich vielleicht raus, wenn ich irgendwann meinen Bootsführerschein mache.
Das Ganze ist so umgesetzt mit diesem blauen Wasserstandsbereich. Im Prinzip ist ein blaues Grafikobjekt hinter diesem Landschaftsbild.
Oh, advanced das Schild, ey.
Und wird über die Pixelzahlen getriggert, die ich über die Rheinpegelstelle umgehe.
Okay, das ist jetzt IO-Proker-spezifisch.
entsprechend dieses Grafikelement sein soll. Vielen Dank Frank, sehr schön.
Haben wir das endlich auf den zweiten Teil aufgearbeitet. Ganz vielleicht sollte
auch mein Smart Home wissen, wie hoch der Weserpegel ist.
Ach guck mal, den Flug kann ich nicht. Hi Andrea, du und Nils habt ihr nach Smart City Use Cases gefragt. Davon habe ich ein paar.
Bei uns ist das zwar so, dass wir die Daten nicht zentral bereitstellen, sondern
eher versprengt. Wir haben zwar eine urbane Datenplattform, sammeln die Daten
auch selber und erheben die, stellen die allerdings aktuell noch nicht an externen
dem Bürger zum Beispiel zur Verfügung.
Ich habe mir die Daten selber besorgt
und davon habe ich tatsächlich jetzt einiges.
Du als Familienvater kennst zum Beispiel die Frage,
du Papa, was machen die denn da bei irgendeiner Baustelle,
die in deiner Nachbarschaft vielleicht so komponiert wird?
Das frage ich mich aber auch.
Es gibt ja bei uns auch Baustellen,
die sind irgendwie gefühlt seit einem Jahr da,
gehen irgendwie immer nur zentimeterweise
weiter.
Und ich frag mich auch, was machen die da eigentlich?
Da hab ich jetzt die
Baustellen aus unserem
Baustellenportal in Home Assistant
integriert, hab also quasi die
Umkreissuche hier einmal...
Aber das müsste ich nicht in meinem Home Assistant haben,
ehrlich gesagt.
Das würde ich mir
einfach über die Webseite angucken.
Also
so oft interessiert es mich dann auch
nicht was mit den Baustellen ist, dass ich das im Home Assistant
bräuchte. Eingerichtet und
weiß jetzt zumindest da in der Nähe
in der Straße, wird die Straße aufgerissen,
ein Abwasserrohr da reinkommt. Aber ich find's
cool, dass es das überhaupt
gibt als API.
Ein Rohrbruch, ein Wasserschaden
oder hier wird Glasfaser gelegt,
falls mein Auge das nicht erkennt, kann ich
zumindest irgendwie ablesen. Ist ja auch aus
so voyeuristischen
persönlichen Interessengründen
ein Ding, ne? Dann haben wir hier eine
relativ große Veranstaltungshalle gepaart mit einem relativ großen Einkaufszentrum und dadurch
recht viele Touristen und die stören uns Einwohner zumindest wenn man mal regelmäßig im Stau
gestanden hat und um das zu vermeiden lasse ich mir hier wenn eine Veranstaltung auftritt hier
ein rotes Symbol einzeigen und mit der aktuellen Wegzeit wohin und kann quasi dann sehen soll ich
das gebiet erst mal großräumig meiden oder nicht bisher ist mir zumindest nicht bekannt dass
irgendjemand eine arena nach mir benannt hätte es gibt doch eigentlich keinen grund wenn das
jemand machen will fühlt euch frei dann habe ich mich jetzt sehr egoistisch noch darum gekümmert
um die daten der nächstgelegenen packstation hier von der lhc besorgen ich stand nämlich
regelmäßig mit paketen vor einer schon vollen packstation und da habe ich keinen bock mehr
drauf gehabt also habe ich mir es gibt eine api für wie viel platz ist in der packstation ja das
ist praktisch die aktuelle parkstation besorgt die dlp und da frage ich quasi ja das ist ab wie
denn jetzt gerade der füllstand beziehungsweise das paketaufkommen in dieser parkstation sein
wird das passiert wochenweise und wir werden da jetzt mal etwas nicht knallrot ist dann kann ich
zumindest mal den weg dorthin gehen das war aber nicht gut aus bei der gerade ich habe auch
neulich im Briefkasten gehabt von DHL, die gefragt haben, ob ich nicht hier selber eine
Packstation in den Vorgarten bauen will.
So als jemand in meinem Berufsfeld bekommt man ja doch das ein oder andere Paket.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie genervt waren.
Sonst musst du vielleicht mal gucken, Flo, ob du bei dir nicht auch noch eine Packstation
irgendwo unterkriegst.
Kann auch meine Pakete da loswerden.
Und dann habe ich ja nicht nur den Wohnsitz hier, sondern eben auch noch in Griechenland.
Und da fällt sowas etwas unter Vorfreude, denn da habe ich die öffentlich zugänglichen
Webcams, zum Beispiel unseres
Strandes oder eines relativ
großen Autos bei uns einmal in Home Assistant
integriert. Das heißt, das sind direkt... Unseres
Strandes? Das hat auch nur einen Schrank. Easy.
Schrand. Easy. ...kreative Kameras jetzt,
die ich in Home Assistant einmal
anzeigen lassen kann. Alle Integrationen,
von denen ich gerade erzähle,
außer die DAL, die habe ich mit
Claude in der Chrome-Extension gemacht.
Das heißt, Chrome kann ja dann den Browser
benutzen. Und da habe ich gesagt, ich möchte gerne
diese Webseite mit zum Beispiel dieser
Webcam oder mit diesen Daten der Baustellen,
hätte ich jetzt gerne mal gerne in Home Assistant
schreibt. Ja gut, das ist dann
halt wieder so Webscraping-Zeug.
Das geht dann halt jetzt, aber
in einem Monat nicht mehr.
... Integration und das
funktioniert tatsächlich sehr gut.
Hab jetzt dafür die Veranstaltungen,
die Webcams von mehreren
Lieferanten,
hab ich jetzt einfach in Home Assistant drin.
Und das ist tatsächlich ganz schick gelöst bis zum nächsten Mal
oder bis November.
Auch ganz nett. Das ist so ein Rundumschlag gewesen.
Ein paar Ideen, also auch gerade mit der Packstation und so ist nochmal ein anderer Input.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Und bis November, mein Flo, bestimmt das Gastspiel.
Da gibt es noch letzte Tickets.
Und auch die Stadt Solingen hat ein Smart City Forum.
Das ist direkt das Wochenende danach.
Die Infos findet ihr auch unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wer in Mannheim aufmerksam durch die Stadt geht, der sieht sie.
Kleine Sensoren an Laternen und Masten.
Hinter ihnen steckt das Stadtklimamessnetz der Smart City Mannheim.
Über 130 Messstationen, die kontinuierlich Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit und Windgeschwindigkeit erfassen.
Für mein Smart Home wollte ich präzise Außentemperaturdaten für genau meine Straße.
Das habe ich ja eben gesagt.
Also präzise Außentemperaturen, wenn sich jemand darum kümmert, die richtig zu messen.
Weil Sonneneinstrahlung oder irgendwelche Nischen oder so, alles verfälscht das.
Die Frage ist natürlich, was ist die korrekte Außentemperatur, aber da sind wir dann auch sehr schnell sehr philosophisch unterwegs.
Und wenn jemand professionell Wetterstationen betreibt, die nutzen zu können, ist natürlich schon ganz spannend.
Wetterdienste wie Open Weather Map interpolieren Werte aus weit entfernten Stationen.
Günstige Zigbee-Sensoren sind ungenau, besonders wenn sie in der Sonne hängen.
und eine eigene professionelle Wetterstation kaufen und warten,
das lohnt sich kaum, wenn ohnehin schon eine geeichte Station direkt bei mir um die Ecke steht.
Der Nachteil im Gegensatz zu einer lokalen Wetterstation ist natürlich,
dass die Daten immer den Umweg übers Internet finden müssen.
Naja, nicht unbedingt.
Nicht unbedingt, wie gesagt.
Ich hab da auch mal mit SCR was abgegriffen hier.
Die funken ja, die Dinger.
Wenn einige von euch vielleicht aus dem Spiel und Zeug Discord kennen,
habe ich deshalb eine Home Assistant-Integration gebaut.
Smart City Mannheim.
Sie lässt sich über HACS installieren.
Man gibt seinen Straßennamen, Stadtteil oder Stationscode ein,
wählt die nächste Station aus
und hat sofort Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit und Windgeschwindigkeit in Home Assistant.
Gibt es...
Gibt es irgendwie sowas in...
Urbane Datenplattform
Frankfurt.de
What the fuck, Alter
WTF
Was ist das für ein krasses Dashboard, Mann
Abgedrehtes Zeug
Direkt von der Station vor der eigenen Haustür
Das ist ja so ein bisschen das, was wir auch in Solingen gesehen haben
Ein super schönes Interface, einfach nur die Adresse einzugeben und dann wird das automatisch vorgeschlagen oder zugeordnet. Finde ich gut.
Zugekommen sind drei weitere Datenquellen, die automatisch mit aktiviert werden.
Der offizielle Pollenflugindex des Deutschen Wetterdienstes mit acht Pollenarten, die Luftqualitätsmessstationen am Friedrichsring mit Feinstaub- und Stickstoffdioxidwerten
und die offizielle DWD-Wetterstation Mannheim inklusive Niederschlag.
Alles in einer Integration, alles direkt in Home Assistant.
Im Sommer vergleiche ich die Außentemperatur der Messstation mit dem Sensor im Wohnzimmer.
Wenn es draußen kühler wird als drinnen, dann bekomme ich eine Benachrichtigung.
Fenster auf.
Morgens das gleiche in die andere Richtung.
Fenster zu, bevor die Hitze reinkommt.
Das klingt jetzt simpel, aber es funktioniert nur, wenn die Außendaten wirklich lokal sind.
Ein Wetterdienst hätte hier nicht gereicht.
Die Integration ist Open Source und auf GitHub verfügbar.
Der Link ist in der Beschreibung. Wer in Mannheim wohnt und Home Assistant nutzt, kann sie direkt einbinden. Mannheim hat über 130 Messstationen und wir können diese Daten direkt in unseren Smart Homes nutzen.
Das ist doch ganz cool. Also tatsächlich finde ich das schon interessant. Also ich meine Soling macht das ja auch jetzt. Und hier aus der Community eine...
Ich muss mal gucken, was es für Frankfurt und Hanau für Werte gibt.
Da habe ich mir noch nie drüber Gedanken gemacht.
Da gibt es bestimmt ein paar richtig nice Sachen,
die man sich für Home Assistant abgreifen kann.
Für Mannheim, wenn jede Stadt oder jeder Landkreis so etwas anbieten würde
und man bekommt direkt für seine Adresse die ganzen Sensoren
und hier ja auch noch Pollenflug und alles, das ist natürlich schon ganz nett.
Da muss man sich die nicht irgendwie aus mehreren Integrationen zusammensuchen.
Genau.
Musst du irgendwie gucken, ja, aber was ist davon eigentlich wo gemessen?
Ich hatte irgendwo auch irgendeinen tollen Sensor, der hatte die Unterteilung in Nord- und Süddeutschland.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen grob, aber das ist natürlich sehr viel netter, wenn das so lokal funktioniert.
Finde ich sehr gut. Und natürlich verlinke ich die ganzen Sachen auch unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ich habe eine Lüftungsautomatisierung entwickelt.
In Karl ist nur eine Wetterstation. Wie kommst du da an die Daten dran?
Weil so lange, ich glaube, von Karl bis hier wird die nicht funken.
Er unterstützt zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, die Fenster in einem Raum zu öffnen und auch wieder zu schließen, um die bestmögliche Luftqualität im Raum zu gewährleisten.
Das ist offenbar das, was Joshua eben gesagt hatte, dass er Außenwerte mit Innenwerten abgleicht.
Nur vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr rein eskaliert. Ich bin interessiert.
Zeugnischen für den Zap.
Ja, das mit dem Partnerjubiläum, wie gesagt, witzig. Ich sehe das überhaupt nicht.
sondern sehr dynamisch und immer abhängig davon, wie die Außen- und Innenwerte der Luft sind.
Zum einen mal wird die Fensteraktivität überwacht.
Finde ich jetzt nicht so spannend.
Was passiert?
Meine Idee funktioniert im Wesentlichen so.
Smart Cities verbauen Sensoren, die den Wasserverbrauch für bestimmte Regionen tracken.
An Knotenpunkten oder Wasserwerken.
Ja, ist das so?
Das löst auch gleichzeitig das Problem der Anonymisierung, weil keine einzelnen Haushalte getrackt werden.
Dadurch kann man in seinem Smart Home den Wasserverbrauch...
Moment, der stellt einfach nur vor, wie er sich das vorstellt, oder was?
ist, holst du die Sekunde
sinkt und wenn der Solarstrom
über 1000...
So, mal gucken.
Was ist denn, wenn man hier nach Smart City
sucht? Gibt es da irgendwas?
Smart City.
Frankfurt.
Smart City Frankfurt.
Digitalisierung.
Okay, boah, der war keine Ahnung.
Zeug.
Psst.
Enpal?
Enpal, das sind doch die mit der...
mit den Solaranlagen, die...
irgendwie zweifelhaften Ruf haben.
Machen wir nochmal Updates.
Ich meine, es ist immerhin schon zwei Stunden her,
dass wir Updates gemacht haben.
Traue ich mich Arch-User-Repos zu updaten?
Ne, traue ich mich nicht.
Genau.
Für Offenbach gibt es da einen Messer-Tracking-Service.
Sowas bräuchte ich für den Hauptbahnhof dann auch.
Messenger.
Ich meine, gehen wird sowas, ne?
Es gibt doch auch
so
Routenplanungs-Apps
fürs Auto,
wo Leute melden können,
wenn an der Stelle
Irgendwie die ampel kaputt ist die polizei steht der bahnübergang kaputt ist und sowas ja so was könnte man eigentlich auch machen
wo leute wo leute irgendwelche
Fragwürdigen anderen leute melden können
Es gibt doch...
Was? Da gibt es eine Seite?
Das habe ich ja...
Was?
Messer-Inzidenz.
Das habe ich ja noch nie gehört.
Das gibt es.
Report.
Und wo kommen die Daten her?
Hier, 4 Inzidenz.
Wo kommen denn die Daten her?
Gucken die irgendwie bei der Polizei oder so?
Police Press Releases across Germany.
Okay, okay.
Moment.
Ist das Frankfurt hier?
Das könnte fast Frankfurt sein.
Ah, ne.
Mülheim.
Das ist auch nicht weit weg.
Gruppe mit Machete bedroht, Alter.
19, das ist heute.
Bahnhofstraße, Mülheim.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so weit weg.
Oh man.
Witzig, dass es da schon eine Seite für gibt.
Oder was heißt witzig?
Witzig ist es ja eigentlich nicht.
Ist eher, ist eher Pains Champ.
Ja.
Aber wie geht das überhaupt?
In Frankfurt ist doch Waffenverbotszone.
Ah, nee, in Mülheim ja nicht.
Ja, direkt Home Assistant API.
Home Assistant Dashboard,
übrigens eine API, ja.
So.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Spannendes.
Äh, Wahrheit über Inkogni juckt mich nicht so.
Was der Tauchlehrer macht, auch nicht.
Passwort-Manager-Tierlist.
Das gucken wir uns nicht an, das Video.
Ich gucke mir nur das Fazit von ihm an, okay?
Was da am Ende rauskommt.
Also, ja, ja.
Also er sagt Kipas Beste.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon hatten.
Nee, ich glaube nicht.
Kipas Beste.
Bitwarden, glaube ich, ist das, oder?
Beste.
Ist das Bitwarden?
Voltwarden?
Oder wie auch immer.
Was das hier ist, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Diesen ganzen anderen Krempel kenne ich nicht.
Ich kenne bloß noch den hier.
Das ist NordVPN Passwort.
Und das sieht aus wie der Apple Keyboard und das Google Keyboard.
Okay, der hat bei mir schon mal Pluspunkte gemacht, weil Keypass ist in der Tat beste.
Sehe ich genauso.
Beste Keypass.
Moment, warum ist das Video auf Englisch?
Ah, Text to Speech.
Mein Gott, YouTube, Alter.
Autodub, ja.
Aber ich will mir kein Video zur Chatkontrolle angucken.
Das geht mir geistig gerade...
Das geht mir zu sehr auf den Sack.
Do not buy LG TVs.
Ja, das hatten wir doch vorhin.
Das hatten wir doch vorhin.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Der hat es hoffentlich ein bisschen genauer beleuchtet.
Da hatten wir es doch vorhin schon.
von
MonkaW.
Halbe Stunde Video, da skippen wir ein bisschen was
vor wieder.
Und Informatik finde ich auch nicht schlecht, ja.
Ich gucke Morpheus auch ganz gern.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich da wirklich
instant auf jeden Upload bei beiden
klicken würde, also nur wenn das Thema mich
interessiert. Aber die machen schon gute Videos.
Guck ich, guck ich beides.
Ja, das haben wir vorhin schon gesehen.
Wie gesagt, den Fail sehe ich da gar nicht so sehr bei Microsoft in diesem Fall,
sondern bei LG, dass überhaupt sowas eingebaut ist in dieser Bestandteil vom Treiber.
By the way, warum braucht ein Monitor überhaupt einen Treiber?
Genau das, was man für einen Monitor haben möchte.
User-Credentials, na klar.
für die erste Zeit, drei Jahre nach dem Kaufen der Monitore.
Alles dank einer Windows-Update.
Alle durch seinen Monitore-App-Installer.
Und das trotz des Installations und des Run-Ups ohne einmal
den User zu fragen oder sie sogar zu ermutigen, um Verwaltung
Tja, mit Linux wäre das nicht passiert, ne?
in der Pipeline, von der wir die Legale beantworten.
In der gleichen Woche hat LG auch Pop-Ups auf bestimmten LG Smart TVs ausgerollt,
Das hat die Welt natürlich gebraucht.
Moment.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, jeder der bei dir mal Fernsehen guckt, den musst du darüber informieren, dass dein Fernsehen sie mitschneidet oder was.
Das ist so idiotisch mittlerweile alles.
Weiterer Grund, warum ich meinen Fernseher nicht ins Internet gehängt habe.
Ich habe ja ein Smart TV.
Da ist irgendein Android TV drauf.
Von Sony ist der.
Und den habe ich nie ins Internet gehängt.
Da ist ein Shield TV dran.
Und das füttert den Fernseher. Rest ist weder im WLAN noch per Kabel angeschlossen.
Das ist ein großer Problem. Das sollte eine sofortige rote Flagge für jeden sein. Und zweitens, die meisten Leute werden das nie sehen. Und es ist wahrscheinlich völlig unverfügbar.
Es gibt viele Fälle, in denen es nicht möglich ist, jemandem legalen Vertrauen zu geben, um mit Mikrofonen in einer Smart TV von LG zu werden.
Zum Beispiel ein Kind, das nicht legal Vertrauen gibt, weil das nicht so funktioniert.
Additionally, it could be an issue of just ...
Musst du den Kindern halt sagen, bei mir könnt ihr keinen Fernseher gucken,
weil ihr mir nicht consenten könnt dazu,
dass der Fernseher die Sprache aufnimmt.
Das ist hirnverbrannt, ey.
You're supposed to tell your friends, like,
hey, thanks for coming over.
Before we get started, some housekeeping rules.
You see that TV over there with the LG logo on it?
Um, just so you know, by coming into my abode,
Du bist in Ordnung, dass unsere Gespräche mit dem Ding aufgelistet werden können, um von LG zu werden.
Und dann werden auch Ads auf den Ads von den YouTube-Videos, die wir mit Ads in ihnen sehen, auflaufen.
Also, um alles klar zu machen, wenn Sie bitte hier signen können, dann können Sie rein und wir können ein paar Cheetos essen.
Ich denke, das ist, wie sie es sich vorstellen.
LG bemerkt auch, dass User, die nicht zu verbessern wählen, Zugang zu Sicherheits-Updaten verlieren.
Das ist ja auch immer das Ding, du kommst bei sowas eigentlich drum herum.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man den Smart TV einfach nie ins Internet,
beziehungsweise nie irgendwie ans Netzwerk hängt, ist das mit Security dann auch kaum ein Problem.
Es ist Teil eines Antikonsum-Kurses, den sie mit ihren TVs und Monitoren gemacht haben.
In Fakt, die neuen Pop-Up-Diskussionen auf LGs TVs scheinen eigentlich ein direkter Ergebnis zu sein,
wenn LGs recentes Settlement mit Texas-Besitzern.
Texas-Besitzer General Ken Paxton hat ein Settlement mit Elektronik-Firma LG
über Fragen über Smart-TV-Privacy.
Das Agreement stoppt LG von der Bewertung von Daten durch automatische Konten-Rekognition-Technologie
ohne die Verwaltung der User.
Moment
LG scannt quasi was du guckst
Verstehe ich das jetzt richtig
Also die scannen
Was du guckst
Für was
Um dir dann Sachen empfehlen zu können
Oder
Oder um deine Daten verkaufen zu können
Unter dem Sitzung muss LG eine Pop-Up-Verkündung auf Smart TVs geben, die erklärt, wie die Beobachtung von Daten geklärt und benutzt wird.
In Paxton's petition against LG, he alleged,
LG secretly monitors what consumers watch across streaming apps, cable and even connected devices like gaming consoles or Blu-ray players.
This isn't a glitch or side effect. It's deliberate.
LG harvests this data, builds profiles of consumers' behavior and sells it for profit.
And the list goes on. In 2024, LG implemented advertisements into its smart TV screensavers.
Alter, jetzt musst du dir schon Werbung angucken, wenn der Screensaver von einem Fernseher angeht.
Das ist mittlerweile alles so lächerlich nur noch.
Und man kommt immer schwerer drum herum.
Es wird immer schwieriger, um so Sachen drumherum zu kommen.
Beam, danke schön für den Sub.
Pog.
25.
It force-installed an unremovable Microsoft-Kill-My-Lens-Service
on users' smart TV home screens,
eventually caving to user backlash
by generously allowing you to delete a shortcut icon.
Okay, jetzt rutsch mal gespannt.
Das ist eine Wasserkühlung für eine Grafikkarte.
Die hat Aufnähe für eine CPU, oder?
Für eine CPU.
Und auf der Wasserkühlung ist ein Display, das quasi Beleuchtung im Rechner machen kann.
Alter, jetzt aber abgedrehtes Kram.
Ja, ich glaube, dass es das schon länger gibt.
Muss ich sagen, meine Wasserkühlung, die hat kein Display.
Tatsächlich, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, der kleinere Teil des Fails liegt hier bei Microsoft,
Der größere bei LG, dass das überhaupt ein Ding ist.
Interessant auch, dass das auf einmal alles Adminrechte hat, gell?
Zum zusätzlich installieren.
Ich mein klar, Windows Update hat Adminrechte, macht irgendwie Sinn.
Wobei, macht es Sinn?
Macht es wirklich Sinn, dass Windows Update Adminrechte hat?
Ich mein, Linux musste immer noch zum Updaten ein Passwort eingeben.
We might not have noticed it, if not for doing what we do.
LG Monitor App Installers sole purpose is to install other apps for your monitor while egregiously advertising subscriptions for McAfee's Scam Detector.
Yes, I will take irony for $1,200 please.
Blower ist nicht neu für Dinge wie vorgestellte PCs und Laptops.
Und es gibt Rückwirkungen zwischen Software-Installer wie McAfee und Norton und den vorgestellten oder Laptop-Sellern.
Das ist leider normal, obwohl es schrecklich ist.
Aber für uns ist es neu.
Ich denke nicht, dass ich jemals ein peripherales, drittpartisches Gerät gesehen habe, das nicht ein volles Computer ist, mit Windows auf dem es installiert ist.
come with Adware to sell you
McAfee and whatever
other bullshit they might pull through their
software service. So this should not be allowed
to spread. Na gut, das Windows
Mist vorinstalliert, das ist ja nichts Neues.
Wisst ihr, was mich immer noch
ein bisschen wundert? Dass diese
Sachen wie McAfee,
Gedöns,
Norton,
Security Suite
und was es da nicht, Abitdefender
und was es da nicht alles gibt, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt, alles.
Dass sich das immer noch verkauft?
Wir sind ja nicht mal 1998.
1998 war das erste, die ersten zwei Sachen, die du neu installiert hast unter Windows, war
Avira Free Antivirus Windows 98.
Dieses Gedöns war das erste, was du damals installiert hast, als erstes.
Und dann, ganz wichtig auch noch damals,
Zone Alarm für Windows 98.
Hier.
Leute, Zone Alarm.
und dann bist du ins Internet erst
Soundalarm war damals
zwingend notwendig
weil
man hat ja teilweise seine Rechner
damals direkt ins Internet gehängt
also das DSL Modem
ging an eine Netzwerkkarte im Rechner
das heißt ein Windows Rechner hatte eine
Public IP
das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
Alter
dass man so dummes Zeug gemacht hat.
Da war kein Router mit NAT davor, zumindest ganz am Anfang nicht.
advertising a 30-day free trial with McAfee.
Na toll.
Although very rarely, the pop-up recommends users install LG's Switch,
Calibration Studio, Dual Controller or Channel.
Boah, wer entwickelt diese Dinge auf diese Art und Weise?
Das ist, wie nennt man das alles? Dark Pattern.
Moment mal, dann Watch Live TV for free LG Channels?
WTF, Alter, ich will doch einfach nur den Monitor anschließen.
Nerv doch nicht rum!
und weil es mit der Internetseite verbunden ist, können sie theoretisch diesen MacAfee Installer und einzuglippen und etwas anderes erstellen.
Klicken auf den McAfee-Link zeigt eine 30-Tage-freie Trial mit Text, der ziemlich klein ist und bezieht sich darauf, dass nach der Trial M-Plus Premium für das erste Jahr 39,99 Euro ist.
Wir wissen nicht genau, was die Verlust der letzten Verleger von unseren Zuschauern über das Thema beizutragen hat, weil es ein bisschen langweilig ist, aber klar ist etwas verändert, das das Problem verursacht hat.
bekommen vom Hersteller und die haben es halt einfach reingehauen.
Dass Microsoft jetzt natürlich
so ewig braucht, um das
quasi einfach
nicht zu verteilen,
das ist ja schon wieder gut. Das ist halt Microsoft-Slob-Scheiße.
Das ist alles, was wir gesehen haben, als wir online gegründet haben.
Unsere aktuellen Fähigkeiten zeigen, dass dieses Problem spezifisch für bestimmte Monitore in LGs UltraGear-Produktlinie ist.
Es kann auch andere beeinflussen.
Editing Steve hier.
Fun Fact.
Einen Tag nach dem Recording dieser Linie, wiederum, wie ich in der Intro gesagt habe,
hat mein Monitor von diesem getroffen.
Und der, den ich gerade schaue, der den Pop-Up hat,
ist in der UltraFine-Linie.
Es ist der 32-Inch-Un-880-B, den ich im Jahr 2023 gekauft habe.
Das ist genau das, mit dem ich mich begrüßen möchte, wenn ich meinen Computer am Arbeitstag schalte.
Etwas, das sich wie Mauer aussehen würde, das ich nicht erwartet hätte.
Von einem Gerät, das ich schon seit drei Jahren gewohnt habe, das ich dachte, dass es eine Art Vertrauen eröffnet hätte.
Aber anyway.
Was die Apps für Auto-Installationen auf Hardware zu verhindern ist,
Ja geil, um das zu fixen, musst du irgendwelche obskuren Group Policies...
Ja, wenn noch.
Ja.
Oh, die App hat ja eine super Bewertung.
So war es.
Ja.
Ja, das darf man ja nicht vergessen. Genau, genau, genau.
Das darf man ja nicht vergessen. Der Kram ist ja auch noch schweineteuer.
Zeigt da nicht nur Werbung an, sondern installiert noch auf deinem Windows-PC irgendeinen Scheiß.
Also das ist halt echt wieder...
Also 2026?
Oder generell
aktuell ist das echt ganz schöner
Abfuck, was so Sachen angeht.
Und das wird ja auch
nicht besser. Ich meine, man muss
sich mal die Qualität angucken, auch
der Software aktuell.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das daran liegt, dass
irgendwie gefühlt noch alles gevibecoded wird,
aber es vergeht ja kaum
ein Windows-Update, wo nicht irgendwelche
grundlegenden Sachen kaputt sind.
Ich habe letztens auf Reddit gelesen, da hat einer geschrieben, dass in der Taskleiste bei ihm keine Icons mehr angezeigt wurden, hier in dieser Traybar. Die Traybar war einfach weg. Und woran lag das? Weil per Group Policy Audio deaktiviert wurde.
Also in irgendeiner Art und Weise hat ChatGPT das in Windows so gevibe-coded, dass hier dieses Tray-Icon an einer aktivierten Soundkarte hängt.
Das halten wir.
EgoVein, wo steht das denn bei euch überhaupt mit dem Partnerjubiläum?
Weil ich seh das nicht, ich seh das auch im Chat nicht.
Wo steht das denn? Steht das irgendwie im Chat, wenn man reinkommt?
Oder wo steht das?
Ich find das witzig, dass ihr das alles seht, aber ich krieg das nicht angezeigt.
Es ist automatisch vorgefüllt im Chat.
Was?
Ach so?
Aha.
Was die alles gibt.
Also alles im Endeffekt.
Wir wurden nicht an irgendeinem Punkt von einer Form von Vertrauen oder Vertrauen für diese Dinge verantwortlich.
Die App wurde installiert, ohne uns zu fragen, ohne unseren Vertrauen.
Sie fuhr ohne unseren Vertrauen.
Und es scheint, dass man die User-Daten, die einmal installiert wurden, ohne Vertrauen,
ohne sogar potenziell die Existenz davon zu wissen.
Und für uns scheint das wahrscheinlich illegal zu sein.
Ich würde mich sehr interessieren, ob das auch in dem gleichen Formen für unsere...
Das Gute ist, hoffentlich werden die bei den Amis wieder krass verklagt, weil wenn du da verklagt wirst, dann kostet es gleich Millionen.
Wenn du LG Monitor hast, ist die Chance, dass du das hattest, recht hoch.
illegal for them to do that. I'm not an expert on GDPR law, but it sure seems that way.
But either way, even if they have an EU model, we'd love to hear from you if you can replicate
this there on something you bought in Europe, because probably there's an avenue there for
a potentially successful lawsuit. But anyway, we're not experts on that stuff, so let's just
keep going with the technicals. OEMs using Windows to install software on user systems
Also ich habe ja einen Gigabyte Mainboard.
Da muss man den BIOS explizit ausschalten, dass das Windows Sachen installiert.
Ansonsten kriegt man irgendeinen RGB-LED-Treiber fürs Mainboard und so mit installiert automatisch.
Auch bescheuert, ne?
Oder habe ich ein Gigabyte Mainboard?
Was hab ich denn? Ich glaube schon, ne?
Ich hab ein
Gigabyte hier, das da hab ich.
Ja gut, okay, jetzt haben wir eigentlich alles
gesehen.
Was zum Teufel ist LG Sports? Alter, ich will doch nur einen Monitor anschließen.
Ah, guck mal, hier gibt es Wireshark-Dumps jetzt.
End quote.
Oh Gott, schonzug.
Alter, das ist so abfuck mittlerweile alles.
Ich werde das bei meinem nächsten Fernseher auch auf jeden Fall wieder so machen wie jetzt.
Aktuell habe ich keine Ambitionen, da irgendwie einen neuen Fernseher zu kaufen, weil er tut immer noch.
Der Fernseher kommt nicht ins WLAN, nicht ins normale Netzwerk.
Da wird einfach nur mein Shield TV oder mein Player, was auch immer, den ich dann habe, angeschlossen und das war's.
Ah gut, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Es ist brüllend.
NKS.
Last week.
Nein.
IT-Totalausfall in Berlin.
Gericht komplett lahmgekriegt.
Oh yeah.
Da haben sie sich bestimmt...
Und da haben sie sich bestimmt wieder nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert.
Genau, manche Geräte gehen gar nicht mehr ohne Internetverbindung.
Also ganz viele Smart Home Geräte brauchen zwingend Handy App plus Account und sowas.
Schau mal.
... Straftäter aus der Untersuchungshaft freikommen.
Nicht, weil sie unschuldig sind, sondern weil die IT der Justiz nicht funktioniert.
Klingt absurd? Genau dieses Szenario droht in Berlin.
Alter, warum? Warum ist das eigentlich immer Berlin, das so am Arsch ist?
Es ist immer Berlin. Was machen die da?
Der Deutsche Richterbund warnt ausdrücklich davor.
Aber was ist passiert? Montagmorgen, halb sieben.
Bei der Berliner Justiz beginnt eine Großstörung.
Richterinnen, Richter und Beschäftigte können sich nicht mehr auf den Servern des landeseigenen IT-Dienstleisters ITDZ einwählen.
Sie kommen nicht mehr an die elektronischen Akten, können keine Fälle bearbeiten und nicht mehr in ihre E-Mails lesen.
Und das trifft nicht nur eine einzelne Behörde.
Die gesamte ordentliche Gerichtsbarkeit steht still.
Alle Amtsgerichte, das Kriminalgericht in Moabit, die beiden Landgerichte und das Kammergericht.
Das hat auch ein Sprecher des Kammergerichts bestätigt.
Wie konnte das passieren und was heißt das für den Rechtsstaat?
Das schauen wir uns nach dem Sponsor dieses Videos an.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von Mammut.
Wer mit KI arbeitet,
Ah, die schon wieder.
Mammut.
Kimi Perplexity.
Und für Bilder unter anderem Recraft.
Oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Modelle direkt.
Die Modelle werden...
...schreibt der IT-Dienstleister ITDZ in einer Mail, dass sie das Problem gefunden haben.
Das steht jedenfalls im Tagesspiegel.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass die Sache damit gelöst ist.
Das heißt nicht, dass es geht.
Techniker ist informiert.
Das System läuft auch am frühen Abend nicht.
Das hat auch die Sprecherin der Senat-Justizverwaltung bestätigt.
Die Gerichte ziehen drastische Konsequenzen und schicken schon mittags alle Beschäftigten nach Hause.
Die müssen einfach wieder Faxe schicken.
Wer im Gerichtssaal steht, muss improvisieren.
Stefan Schifferdecker, der stellvertretende Landeschef des Deutschen Richterbundes in Berlin, bringt es auf den Punkt.
Er spricht von einem vorübergehenden Stillstand der Rechtspflege.
Die Richterschaft ist wütend, weil sie ihre Arbeit nicht machen kann.
Man nimmt Stift und Papier und verhandelt ohne Akten.
Die Richterinnen und Richter haben zu dem Zeitpunkt gezweifelt, ob es am Dienstag weitergeht.
Kommen wir nochmal zurück zu dem Szenario vom Anfang.
Den Haftfristen. Warum ist das so brisant? Das regelt § 121 der Strafprozessordnung.
Untersuchungshaft darf ohne Urteil grundsätzlich nur sechs Monate dauern. Länger geht es nur in
begründeten Ausnahmefällen und darüber muss zwingend ein Oberlandesgericht entscheiden.
Reißt die Justiz diese Frist, muss sie den Haftbefehl aufheben. Und wichtig,
eine überlastete Justiz zählt vor Gericht regelmäßig nicht als ausreichender Grund
für eine Verlängerung. Wenn also wegen eines IT-Ausfalls Verhandlungstermine platzen oder
Akten nicht rechtzeitig zum Oberlandesgericht kommen, dann passiert genau das, wovor der
Richterbund warnt. Die Justiz muss Beschuldigte freilassen, nicht weil sie freigesprochen
wurden, sondern weil die Technik versagt hat. Aber es gibt auch eine gute Nachricht. Nach
dem aktuellen Stand ist es dazu nicht gekommen. Die Gerichte haben die Todmachnahmen gegengesteuert.
Im Amtsgericht hier am Montag erklärt die Senat jetzt die Ursache. Und da gab es zunächst
widersprüchliche Angaben. Am Montag erklärt die Senat Justizverwaltung, es handele sich
ein Lizenzproblem bei einer Schnittstellensoftware, also bei der Software, mit der sich die Beschäftigten
überhaupt erst auf die Server einwählen.
Einen Tag später klingt das anders.
Da nennt das ITDZ ein Software-Update aus der Vorwoche als Ursache.
Schon in den Tagen davor hatte das Update für einzelne Störungen gesorgt.
Beide Erklärungen betreffen dieselbe Zugangssoftware.
Wie genau Lizenzproblem und Update zusammenhängen, haben die Behörden bisher nicht offiziell aufgeklärt.
Nach Informationen des Tagesspiegels stammt die Netzwerksoftware von einem US-Hersteller.
Welcher das ist, sagen weder IDDZ noch die Justizverwaltung öffentlich.
Wichtig zur Einordnung, die viel kritisierte elektronische Akte war diesmal nicht die Ursache.
Die Berliner Justiz nutzt dafür das sogenannte elektronische Integrationsportal, kurz EIP.
Das ist auch wieder so typisch deutscher Name, oder? Elektronisches Integrationsportal.
Und das war beim Totalausfall eher Opfer als Auslöser.
Das war schlicht nicht erreichbar, weil der Zugang zu den Servern fehlte.
In der Nacht zu Dienstag nimmt das ITDZ das Update dann zurück.
Danach funktioniert die Anmeldung wieder. Eine Nebenwirkung gibt es trotzdem.
Die Richterinnen und Richter sagen, dass dabei wohl auch Druckereinstellungen verloren gegangen sind.
An einer dauerhaften Lösung arbeitet das ITDZ jetzt zusammen mit dem Hersteller.
Und wie sieht es aktuell aus?
Seit Dienstag arbeiten die Straf- und Zivilgerichte wieder, aber nicht im Normalbetrieb.
Vereinzelt hakt die Anmeldung weiter und die Systeme laufen langsamer als gewohnt.
Die Justizverwaltung erklärt das mit einer vorübergehend höheren Systemauslastung.
Ein Sprecher der Kammergerichte fasst es so zusammen.
Das Groß der Beschäftigten kann aber wieder arbeiten.
Das eigentliche Problem ist aber größer als dieser Ausfall.
Denn die Störung gibt es schon lange.
Bereits Ende Februar, Anfang März machte die IT Probleme.
Die neue Richterinnen- und Richtervereinigung schrieb schon am 27. Februar einen offenen Brief an die Justizsenatorin
und wies auf wiederkehrende Störungen des EIP-Systems hin.
Es gab keine nennenswerte Reaktion. Stattdessen verschärften sich die Probleme. Erst am Freitag vor dem Totalausfall fielen die Systeme stundenlang aus. Und im Gegensatz zu dem aktuellen Ausfall ist bei diesem Dauerproblem die E-Akte sehr wohl im Fokus. Die Richterin und Richtervereinigung sieht ihre Einführung als ein Kernproblem und fordert an.
Wir wissen jetzt ja, was Sache ist.
So, uns das nicht genauer angucken.
Das ist echt...
Also...
Weiß nicht, was die da immer treiben.
Ich meine, letztendlich muss man ja auch mal sagen, es kochen alle nur mit Wasser, ja?
Ausfälle wird es immer geben, egal was du...
Doch wie aufwendig du das machst, ja.
Detecting the Hobbits to Eisengard.
Guard, guard, guard, guard, guard.
Finger weg von diesem Mini-PC.
Warum?
Wenn ihr gerade mit dem Gedanken spielt, einen günstigen China-Mini-PC zu kaufen...
Ja, das Problem ist, dass der RAM so teuer ist.
Wartet bitte, bis ihr dieses Video gesehen habt.
Denn was wir beim B-Max B6 Plus für 220 Euro gefunden haben, ist nicht einfach nur ein schlechtes Produkt,
es ist ein Minenfeld aus Sicherheitslücken,
illegalen Windows-Lizenzen,
Ihr nutzt doch bestimmt auch irgendeine RAN-Software, garantiert.
Und sogar Start-Software.
Ausgelegt in der Videobeschreibung.
Fangen wir mit dem installierten Windows an.
Da haben wir nämlich schon die erste Auffälligkeit in den Windows-Sicherheitseinstellungen.
Es ist kein Trusted-Plattform-Modul vorhanden.
Also kein TPM. Das ist gleich aus zwei Gründen ungewöhnlich.
Kann Windows überhaupt installiert werden ohne TPM?
Erhalten eigentlich alle Intel-Mobilprozessoren ab der 8. Core-I-Generation ein Firmware-TPM.
Zum anderen verlangt Windows 11 bei der Installation zwingend ein TPM 2.0.
Wie kann das also sein?
Die Erklärung liegt in der verbauten CPU.
Es handelt sich um ein Intel Core i3-1000NG4 Ice Lake.
Und dieser Chip ist eine ganz besondere Variante.
Intel hat ihn nämlich im Jahr 2020 als Sonderanfertigung exklusiv für Apple aufgelegt.
Verbaut wurde er damals unter anderem im MacBook Air Retina aus dem Jahr 2020.
Die Modelle mit einem N im Namen haben die Besonderheit, dass sie eben kein Firmware-TPM enthalten.
Apple braucht das eben nicht für seine Macs.
B-Max hat sich vermutlich günstig diese Restbestände der Apple-Sonderchips besorgt und verlötet sie nun fleißig in seinen Mini-PCs.
Damit Windows 11 trotz des fehlenden TPM überhaupt installiert werden kann, nutzt B-Max eine Deployment-Software.
Das hat allerdings massive Konsequenzen für die Käufer.
Das mitgelieferte Windows 11 in der Version 24H2 läuft zwar und bekommt auch die normalen Updates,
aber die großen jährlichen Feature-Upgrades funktionieren nicht.
Wir haben versucht, dass im Herbst 2025...
Aber Windows, keck, wait, Alter.
...wird also in weniger als einem Jahr quasi zu einer...
...stellen ausgelesen, dabei...
...ersetzt.
Diese Mühe macht sich der Herr...
...Klartext...
...sollte das aber auf keinen Fall tun.
Diese Abbilder überschreiben nicht nur ungewöhnliche Office-Arbeiten völlig aus.
Werfen wir noch einen kurzen Blick auf die Performance.
Mit aktuellen Mobilprozessoren kann der Ice Lake doppelt keiner nicht mitteilen.
Im Sinne Bench 2024.
Mit Linux wäre das nicht passiert.
So Leute, ich sehe gerade.
Oder ich glaube gesehen zu haben, dass es jetzt Essen gibt.
Exzellent.
Mal gucken, wie es mir nachher geht.
Sollte es mir nachher deutlich besser gehen, dann machen wir Set Servers.
Es wird mal wieder Zeit, dass wir das abschließen.
Ich gehe jetzt erstmal was futtern
Ihr seht uns, Leute
Bis dann, macht's gut, CU